oh you know Vladimir Putin's talking
about nukes or whatever the other day we
were like oh man you know world war
three because this uh NATO thing you
know NATO is basically like somebody
sabotage something and if you come for
us we will retaliate with Collective
force and we're like what does that mean
but it does sound like we're you know
we're walking into what I would consider
to be like World War III territory and
then today Vladimir Putin announces he's
annexing for uh regions I suppose of uh
Ukraine and then Vladimir Vladimir sorry
Vladimir zolinski formally files to join
NATO
and if that actually happens
it is World War III this would mean that
NATO enters in uh would admit Ukraine
into the military Alliance fully
understanding that they are currently at
War but of course they do NATO is
basically funding the entire operation
so why would NATO say no to Ukraine hey
we all knew what was going on let's just
make it
official how about that so we'll talk
about that plus a bunch of other stories
text messages from Elon Musk released oh
this one's going to be funny uh Elon may
have to buy Twitter
so that'll get interesting before we get
started head over to timcast.com become
a member in order to support our work we
got all these hard-working journalists
every day cranking out these stories
fact checking and writing away and field
reporting on the ground all for you and
as members you are supporting their work
so if you want to see more of that
become a member you will also get access
to our other shows like Cass Castle
tales in the inverted world and of
course Tim cast IRL uncensored Monday
through Thursday at 11 PM don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this Channel and be the notification
people keep saying they're not getting
notifications some have said they've
started coming back but it's it's very
likely that uh well I'll I'll put it
this way YouTube specif specified they
are suppressing content because they're
worried about Miss and disinformation
and this right before the midterms so if
you think what we talk about and the
news that we report on is important then
be the notification and share this video
on any social media platform you got
joining us today to talk about this and
so much more is our good friend Will
Chamberlain good to be here senior
council at the internet accountability
project in the article 3 project
and looking forward to talking about
well I guess I'm not looking forward to
talking about we're facing world war
three
a big fan of Dilbert very happy to have
him here uh with us here I forgot about
it
that's right that was your old man and
and guys okay I promise I promise it's
over
or or is it
no no no more
what are you doing no more Goofs I
promise I'm just kidding I just wanted
to see how you guys would react I had a
lot of things to get off my chest uh
this week so I I thank you so much for
being patiently with me as we had this
burden lifted away from all of us and
okay we're gonna be serious and this is
why I'm wearing a very serious shirt
that says I identify as hyperinflation
with our wonderful Bodacious inspiration
to us all that you could get on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com because you
do that this is why I'm here thank you
again so much for having me and dealing
with me and my my humor and my I like
that shirt a lot my pranks and my Goofs
hey everyone I did my part I'm doing my
part to preserve World Peace by learning
the Cyrillic alphabet last night I
believe I have it memorized so I'm going
to recite it really quick it's a
I did it I learned letter by letter last
night on the internet and then I was
memorizing I just kept repeating it I
repeated it like 15 times what what the
way to do it is you do as many as you
can until you mess one up and you start
over and you do that until you can get
it in one playthrough and then you
repeat the play through eight or more
times and after that you'll have it
memorized a lot of people don't know
this but Luke only reads Cyrillic yeah
his computer it translates all art it's
all English yeah but it's just it's all
scribbles full disclaimer there are two
silent letters that don't make a sound
it's a soft accent and a hardness are
you saying Tim cast the IRL has been
infiltrated by the Russians no he's
polish that's right sorry you forget
infiltrated by the polls and the great
thing about NATO so we're good so really
because it's phonetic so if you see the
letters on a on a map on a screen you
can just pronounce them each
phonetically there's no like ois going
or anything there's nothing like that in
Russian oh yeah English is bizarre yeah
it's very easy to read once you know
what the letters are have fun with it
well we are all preparing for world war
three differently I'm just here pushing
buttons in the corner and I'm excited to
hear what we have to talk about I just
want to bring something up before we
start the show
so uh got big news this New Year's
we have acquired something called the
North End domination of Times Square
which is there's two towers there's the
ball drop tower in the North Tower
on the North Tower is a series of ads
two of them I think belonged but like
overtly belong to like Coke or something
you can't get them we bought all the
other ones so on New Year's Eve and we
don't we don't have 100 control of it we
get I think we're getting 10 but this
means on New Year's Eve with everybody
watching all around the world and CNN
standing there you are going to see Tim
cast on the entirety of the tower Left
Right top bottom sides and I'm trying to
figure out exactly what it should say
but it should say something good yeah
something very good and along with this
we are also cordially invited to New
York's official Times Square VIP Elite
party where the politicians are going to
be and uh we're bringing Luke I'm
excited to do this I'm excited to mingle
with the Illuminati
Juliana will be there and you'll be like
you know what happened it was it so this
is it's going to be on during the New
Year celebration
and um
you know the the whole point of doing it
I guess is
I we have a story today we'll maybe talk
about Trevor Noah quitting and I'm just
looking at the ratings collapse of all
these channels the rise of Independent
Media seeing what the daily wire's been
pulling off and what what we are able to
accomplish and
you know there's a lot of people who
have the means but they don't do this
kind of stuff but I'm I'm all about it
I'm 100 culture Warrior baby so we are
going to have I think it's five
different Billboards all at once on the
whole Tower and uh we got to figure out
exactly what we want to say but it's
going to say something fun there are
restrictions but it can say something
cool like you are not the elite anymore
something like that watch Tim cast IRL
or whatever and it's gonna it's just the
whole thing is we are we are taking over
the cultural spaces we are we are
pushing them out we are taking the
spaces they have seated and then we are
going to be standing there in the party
with New York politicians and you know
corporate Elites I I I was I was kind of
shocked when they when I talked to the
company about this and they said yeah
you know we'll get you in the party and
I'm like are you sure and they're like
yeah and I'm like okay
I'm like because it's not like we're
gonna have to fool or anything but but
it's it's going to be really interesting
to say the least so I just wanted to I
just wanted to say that and I wanted to
say thank you to everybody who supports
the show
we weren't sure exactly if we wanted to
do this because I was like does it
really matter that we are going to have
this massive portion of Times Square on
New Year's and I talked to a few people
and the answer was kind of like a yeah
probably because that's a that's a
that's a big statement to make
especially when they're constantly
smearing us and lying about us in the
media just to just to assert ourselves
above them oh yeah and then have it be
on every TV screen when Times Square is
shown all around the world for the
countdown it's good do something like
just seriously inspirational because
then no one can complain and if they do
they look like a fool I don't know I was
kind of you know
do we want to have a chip on our
shoulder and insult The Establishment or
do we want to just brag and be alike
we're here baby yeah pump up the kids
man give them something to live for
that's a good point or just send a
message that makes them think and breaks
the conditioning
that would be powerful that's why you're
gone yeah typically it's been um me Luke
Ian and Michael malice on the uh on the
ads that we've done Times Square I'm
thinking maybe we go with the same thing
that'd be cool but we'll see we'll see
what we got let's read the news let's
jump into the story from the guardian
Ukraine applies for NATO membership
after Russia annexes territory Vladimir
zielinski dismisses Moscow ceremony as a
farce and rules out negotiations with
Putin there you go there uh there he is
he signed the paperwork I thought it was
funny because like I don't know what
that paperwork says if all I know it
could be like an order form for
Giordano's or something you know right
but he signed it and we watched him do
it and he said it was to join NATO if
Ukraine were admitted into NATO right
now we would formally be in World War
III correct because of Article Five yes
what is the Article Five is that you've
got to defend the new Alice yeah common
defense but if they're already at War
then they wouldn't trigger Article Five
as far as I don't I don't know actually
but I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure that
effectively that's saying we're at War
and that Russia is now more of the NATO
alliance yeah it's a mutual Alliance
pack so if one member of NATO gets gets
attacked all of NATO has to come in and
protect that one particular country that
got attacked but I think the wage sorry
go ahead I think I think things work is
if if you're not in NATO when you get
attacked you can't be like oops hey guys
can I rejoin nato in retrospect no you
weren't in NATO people aren't gonna let
them in that's the that's the way this
whole conundrum gets solved is that NATO
is not going to admit Ukraine right you
know I I lean towards that because it
seems absurd for her and like you need
one NATO member state to be like yeah
but considering the fact that NATO's
basically already involved
I mean it's you know it's one thing to
be already involved is another thing to
be a formerly at War my understanding
correct if I'm wrong is
they say that the attacked Nation gets
to dictate the terms of the of the
assistance I don't know let me let's
let's let's let's pull up Article Five
of NATO right I think and I could be
wrong I thought it was something like
you know if like France is attacked then
France says okay we need help and you
guys are going to supply us with this
this is how World War One got started
with a bunch of defensive packs well
this is I want to avoid that I was just
going to say that I was gonna say
historians reading our current history a
hundred years from now are going to be
like these idiots didn't figure out from
the first world war that they shouldn't
have huge alliances and packs and
protecting each other there was a second
world war and a third world war world
and of course there's that famous
Einstein quote about World War III being
fought with weapons that are unknown but
World War four and five being fought
with sticks and stones I'm butchering
the quote here but but you get the gist
of what I'm saying here and this is just
an atrocious situation that is extremely
dangerous for everyone and it's
ridiculous we said World War five world
war four World War World War five yeah
it was like I know not uh I'll pull it
up just because I know not uh what
weapons World War World War III would be
fought with but I know that World War I
will be fought with sticks and stones
yes and then he goes on to say that
world war five is going to be lit yeah I
was like oh wow it's a really terrible
situation I mean it's first off it's
it's terrible that we have Russia
annexing like parts of Ukraine and
saying well this is now Russia because
that's that that puts Putin in a place
where he doesn't have like an easy way
to back down I mean oh that's impossible
right right he can't back down he can't
I mean he can't but neither neither can
any other Russian leader if someone were
to take over after him right kind of
like saying this is what I wanted now
I've got it so leave me alone a little
bit but I mean he's saying that Russian
territory or sorry Ukraine Ukrainian
territory is now Russian territory and
so I mean it kind of eliminates the
possibility of some sort of compromise
territorial compromise uh because you
know ultimately
you want Russia you know I mean you want
a negotiated agreement here I think we
all think that's best because we don't
want World nuclear war if if Putin is uh
dying like they say is and someone else
comes in
that's it what do you do then seed your
newly annexed territory back to Ukraine
you don't liberate it it's also
important to note here that the person
that is uh most most likely to take over
for Putin is more of a Warhawk than he
is we're also in a place where Russia
hasn't officially declared war even
though we are in a in a war obviously
he's still calling it a limited Military
operation but I I do think that that
this setup could be the larger setup for
the use of nuclear weapons smaller
tactical nuclear weapons but also this
could be with his annexation of four new
territories and regions today an excuse
to call out for a full all-out war and
then he's going to attack the
infrastructure he's going to get on the
energy grid and then truly we will see a
very large escalation and and will you
know I I I agree with you but I disagree
with you when you said you know NATO is
going to say no because with how crazy
this situation has been already with how
far it has been asked escalating who
knows if if NATO says the situation got
even crazier he used nukes let's just
accept Ukraine right now and just make
it official it I see that as a small
possibility uh but right now unlikely
but who knows what how far we're gonna
go like I think that in the world where
Putin actually did use tactical nuclear
weapons I don't know what NATO would do
and I mean that's a terrifying world I
don't think they retaliate yeah there
was a there's a really funny quote that
I read I can't remember who it was um
who it was from but they said if Russia
were to Nuke a NATO member State NATO
would not respond with a nuclear strike
against Russia they said you would have
to the president would have to be a
Madman to sacrifice Boston for uh what
was it uh what's the what's the Polish
that he pausing in pause none pause none
yeah he said you'd have to be a Madman
to sacrifice Boston for posnan well you
know there's a lot of things that we
also have to understand here especially
when it comes comes to our chain of
command
which is in the hands of some very crazy
people uh and and incompetent people and
people who of course don't have their
brains working correctly as well so all
the possibilities are on the table here
and this is why the situation is so
dangerous and it's not just Joe Biden at
the helm here it's individuals like
Victoria Newland who of course have an
agenda to push this conflict to the
furthest extent that she could possibly
see it the United States is answering
today by announcing 12.3 billion dollars
additionally to Ukraine as a part of a
U.S government shutdown Bill Biden also
just announced new sanctions Poland is
handing out radiation pills this is this
is this is crazy as of course there's a
major battle now happening in in Lyman a
major key City that's going to decide
this conflict in in a very Major Way
within the next coming days and and also
there's battles around a Ukrainian power
plant things are are absolutely absurd
and I think they reached a point where I
think there's no going back from it
sadly I wish I there was but this to me
is is is dangerous and extremely
extremely horrible for everyone involved
here so what have you guys done to
prepare for a nuclear war learn Cyrillic
by man that's one way to start nice not
telling you he's saying it's for World
Peace but the reality is he thinks
Russia is going to win so he's getting
ready to avoid right he's Conflict at
all no when we're when we're in the
gulags the actual Russian ones he's
going to be the guy making sure we get
food by talking it's like the man in
High Castle but in Reverse right like
basically like the Russians have taken
over the United States and Ian's found a
position among the the occupying
government I I learned that the best way
to avoid death and destruction and chaos
is diplomacy so I'm rolling with that
one
um what about what about you will have
you built your underground bunker yet no
no I haven't done that I'm still living
in Arlington which seems unwise
that's like the worst place zero yeah
right I don't even think like the world
leaders would be there no I think
they'll you know they'll retire to some
bunker in Oklahoma yeah I don't see the
I don't see world war three here what
are you what were you saying um I do
have a friend with a nuclear bunker
there you go hell yeah yeah a nuclear
just like Bush said it
um I just paid him a visit a couple
weeks ago so I'm looking says come on
over I would like to visit just for fun
that'd be cool yeah if you guys want to
come I'm looking at the end shout out to
Joe Buick nice I'm looking at what I
actually got annexed it's for uh what is
called oblasts Donetsk uh zaprazisha I
don't know how you pronounce it
Crimean 2014 but what it does is it
takes Highway M14 which is the East West
Highway from Russia and it goes east or
Goes West rather to it also took Highway
East 105 and East 97 that go north south
so he took the East-West Highway that
connects to these two north-south
highways that take you down out of
Crimea they want a Trade Post in
sevastopol that's the whole point is to
be able to move military and trade stuff
into the Mediterranean at this point I
don't understand why they're not in NATO
with us and one of our best trade allies
they have so much resources they're a
federation like the United States it's a
Federated group of states well
strategically geopolitically China is
also emerging as a power that is
threatening American hegemony and if you
were uh you know calling American
foreign policy I think it would be in
the best interest to have good relations
with either of those countries in order
to make sure that they don't come
together I think we've done the opposite
of that and I think we're creating a
situation that that truly is
highlighting a West versus East
situation which is not beneficial to
anyone it has to be on purpose you know
I'm I'm in many circumstances well
beyond believing in coincidence and
considering what Joe Biden's how he's
been very favorable or deferential to
China this greatly benefits China yeah
you know the US and Russia fighting some
some have actually argued I think we're
talking about the other day that China
may have been the one who sabotaged
Nordstrom to force Russia and NATO to
fight so that they could then make a
move on time I could see that I could
see I mean I could see a third you know
third parties who wanted to just inflame
things further yeah and that that that
makes sense to me it makes more sense to
me than Russia doing it which just is
completely ridiculous but they're saying
they're saying there are a bunch of
articles that it was like people are
pushing conspiracy theories that the
West destroyed the North Street and
they're all citing Anonymous government
sources saying 100 it was Russia 100 I'm
like where's the evidence where's the
proof and and the person even saying
this is not putting their name behind
this a part of the US government
intelligence agencies that of course
everyone's naming as a source who's the
source I I tweeted I said so let me get
this straight the official narrative is
that Russia their own Pipeline and not
say their enemies who they're currently
at war with like that's just nuts if I
see two guys and they're screaming at
each other and they're like you know if
I ever see them and knock you out and
then the guy is found knocked out
outside of the other dude's house I'm
not gonna bet you must hit himself
that's yeah right I mean Biden said he
would yeah I know he said it he's like
oh yeah we'll make Nordstrom go away and
then when and where he was like oh other
guy did that not me what what I love the
media it's just it's you know maybe this
is where it's become so laughably absurd
that people just can't accept it anymore
yeah David Frum had a thing he had a
tweets thread where he was talking about
how he wrote an article called
unpatriotic conservatives back in 2003
about people who opposed a rock you know
who were correct about that absolutely
um and now he's like yeah the
unpatriotic conservatives are back my
article aged really well and it's the
people who are you know doubting the U.S
intelligence Services account that
um Russia blew up its own pipeline yeah
imagine the hubris right just the level
of one you can't be if you question our
intelligence agencies which have been
routinely wrong and also lied to
Americans routinely then you are not
patriotic or you are I mean it's the the
number of different like logical leaps
you have to take to get to David from's
reasoning I I wouldn't even push back I
wouldn't say they were wrong I think
they were deliberately lying I think
they had an agenda they had profits that
they wanted to get they had people that
they needed to please and I think they
deliberate he said yeah they got wmds
when they knew they didn't as of course
the United States government also had
the receipts to the chemical weapons
that they were selling to Iraq when Iraq
was fighting with Iran and what did the
war in Iraq do well it created Isis it
allowed Iran to have a larger sphere of
influence in the entire Middle East it
allowed of course the destruction and
the death of what people estimated to be
over a million people why did we do this
wmds yeah I don't know I'm reading a
book about the CIA right now which is
actually very good and and the the
overall lesson of this book so far is
that the CIA has a reputation for like
secrecy and competence but it's actually
just absurdly stupid and has made huge
mistakes I think you know early in the
Cold War what they did their their whole
plan was like we're going to create
these little partisan armies and all the
Communist States and they just dropped
it like dropped partisans you know and
and refugees they just dropped them in
or like go infiltrate the government and
they all died all the agents yeah they
just all died like all of them
everywhere like in the Korean War they
dropped a bunch of Koreans into North
Korea all of them captured killed
everyone yeah just one comment really
quickly if I was the CIA I would be also
pretending to be really stupid in order
to cover for all my illegal actions and
horrible crap that I did right right
right well will that may be but we all
know the real reason behind this
conflict
from the new New York Intelligencer
Putin de cries U.S Satanism in bizarre
speech annexing parts of Ukraine did you
guys see this Putin said uh it was kind
of crazy he said that the West Was
satanic and he said that they're doing
gender experiments on children or
something to that effect he he gave a
37-minute speech in in the middle of
Moscow huge crowds and he said that that
the West is quote sheer Satanism and
it's turning turning away from moral
neural norms and religious values while
offering children sex change operations
so is he wrong he's not wrong but he's
but but he's not an angel himself I know
he he he you know he he brought up a
good point let's we let's be honest and
I think he he's not wrong in in some of
these instances but but again that
doesn't make him the the good guy here
right I think you know it's like it
reminds me of that I think something
Jack told me about RT or how he
described RT is like RT tells the truth
about us and lies about Russia whereas
our media lies about uh lies about us
and might tell the truth about Russia
right right right so it's like it's like
you have to you listen to Russia to talk
about our problems and you're like yeah
that's actually a fairly accurate
description of how our government is
behaving he's gotta you know you gotta
watch RT to if you want to learn about
what's going on with protests and
activism this is the funny thing about
how they destroyed the lives of all
these RT uh reporters and personalities
yeah back when um when was it was like a
couple years ago I think it was that's
only 17 or something is when they
started hammering I think it was the 18
maybe no it was recently like Lee camp
for instance yeah you know we've known
him for a long time and like he's not a
Russian agent he's like a regular
American dude and he's like left-leaning
but they they ban his podcast which was
unrelated to RT simply because he worked
for RT Chris hedges too another very
famous journalist again on the left also
banned and labeled Russian uh propaganda
Abby Martin Abby Martin got a heart well
uh didn't Larry King work for RTG he did
yep so so here's what they so did Jesse
Ventura RT looks for people who have
opinions that are bad for the West they
hire them and let them do their thing
basically funding these kind of these
kinds of narratives I've recently been
coming really disliking this East-West
narrative like it's the line of
demarcation runs through London are you
kidding me like that's not British
Empire crap and now they want to segment
us into one area and say that Russia and
China dude the West is China West China
is west of me right now that's the West
I'm not gonna play this british-centric
game anymore
that was basically the idea right yeah
London yeah they wanted to take control
of The Narrative of who's where on Earth
and say that they're in the middle it's
crazy well they're the ones who have the
the zero the King which is Greenwich
Mean freaking Bank of international
settlements in Switzerland look at that
man and English is spoken basically
everywhere yeah you go to Japan and
there's like the street signs and the
highways are in English and Japanese
colonists man they tried to colonize
China just like they did to India they
tried with the Opium Wars and they
failed and that's a big part of why
there's so much aggression Putin
actually said it is neo-colonialism and
he said this is great he said the West
is racist for spreading russophobia I'm
like okay I don't know what you're
trying to say like what part of the US
is Satanist is it the woke stuff because
that's what you're saying like
they he's he he plays this a similar
game right yeah I don't care which
government some people someone super
Chatters the other day saying like no no
Putin's fighting evil and I'm like okay
no Putin launched an aggressive war and
invaded his neighbor right that's bad
and I think and it starts and it
kick-started all of this right it's not
a defensive War you're right it is a war
of aggression but it's a war of
aggression where your enemy has Rockets
right on the border of the country next
to you so like who's the aggressor it's
just it's just it's just I mean two
wrongs don't make a writing this isn't I
mean I don't know I'm sorry like they're
I I've there are situations where in a
seemingly aggressive war is actually
someone responding to acts of War by the
other side I think the classic example
of that is the uh Six Days War
where Israel was you know Egypt put in
place a naval blockade of the Red Sea
and prevented Israel from accessing and
shipping anything out of its Southern
port and so it had if it wanted to ship
anything to Asia to go all the way
around Africa right and that's that's
clearly like act of War violence and so
even though Israel struck first in terms
of like actually military assets
striking other military forces I think
it's pretty clear that that was that was
not an aggressive war in the sense of
they were they were the first wronged
party in terms of work like an act of
war against themselves this conflict
goes back and forth for many decades now
and and you could Point hey Russia did
this hey NATO did this and and you can
make a legitimate arguments that are
very convincing by by both sides to me
both of them are being idiots i i people
shouldn't be dying for governments
politicians should be fighting their own
words Wars and shouldn't be sending
innocent people to do it but but you
made a very very very good point there
uh talking about The Six Day War being
brought on by of course the stopping of
trade and trade routes and and denying
countries resources it is what usually
Sparks Wars so this is why the the
bursting of this pipeline is so
important because it could be that major
galvanizing event that starts all of
this it's also why turning Ukraine
against Russia in 2014 with that
Revolution whether or not the CIA was
involved or not I hear they were I don't
know but that is you could argue that
that's kind of an act they cut off their
access to the Black Sea like that's at
least a Sebastopol yeah no that was I
mean that was a huge screw-up and I
think uh I mean the U.S diplomacy there
was appalling I mean there's no we had
no business overturning that government
like yeah John McCain was there okay it
goes back it goes back before the Syria
for instance Russia's got a base in
Tartus the U.S is basically aligned
against Assad uh the Assad regime who is
aligned with Russia and every effort we
made hurt Russia's interests in Tartus
so of course you can go back in time as
long as you want to go back in time you
will always find something absolutely
absolutely and you know 2014 John McCain
was there the CIA was there Victoria
Newland was there she was again pushing
for a lot of the protests there and and
she did have an impact and and this is
the result of this that we're seeing
here and I I think Putin was baited into
a conflict and as soon as he sent troops
there
um this has escalated to a very severe
level who do you point to for
responsibility I think all of them are
responsible I think all of them were
being stupid and I think all of them
need to stop immediately before they
jeopardize the the human civilization
yeah the liberal economic order does not
need to patrol Russia anymore it's they
all know that the New World Order is
coming that George Bush Senior was
talking about it in the late 80s like
they're ready for it now we need to
transition to a New World Order where
we're not at war with Russia there could
be our most potential greatest Ally it's
really weird no one wins Wars
politicians bankers and and
multinational corporations win wit Wars
but no one else wins it's ideology and
it's a question of
I would say perhaps it's a bit reductive
but not having access to classified
documents Vladimir Putin does not want
to be subservient to Nato the U.N to the
world economic forum that doesn't mean
he's a good guy it means he's standing
in the bank like I ain't doing it and
they're like there's more of us than you
and we're stronger and he's like don't
care try me
so there's no he's going to be our
greatest Ally if if uh you know a
communist authoritarian came up to you
in and said work with me to throw people
in a gulag would you do it uh not no I
would say no so I'm not saying that's
what is literally happening between the
two Powers I'm saying there is a line
where you would be like I will never
work with you we will not be allies
because the ideologies are just too
disparate yeah it would be I don't want
to adhere to the world economic forums
laws and sanctions and and give
corporations the ability to sue American
taxpayers if they if we don't buy their
products like that's what the trade the
TPP trans-pacific partnership wanted
with their investors State dispute
settlement Clause that got Trump thank
God overturned I don't want that stuff
either I don't think Putin wants that
crap I think so so we need to build
something better but we're not going to
do it if we're at War but see Russia is
doing this is doing something similar
that when they're they're trying to
build up the Russian Trade Federation
they there's been I guess maybe it's a
bit hyperbolic to say but you know Putin
just said today I guess it's maybe what
I don't know what the time zone is that
the fall of the Soviet Union was was it
was was terrible and the leaders left
them all the people to just fend for
themselves he has consistently expressed
dismay at the fall of the Soviet Union
and it looks like all of his actions
that he's been doing in terms of
building up this Federation he wanted
Ukraine to join the Russian Trade
Federation he wants to build what the
West is also doing so it's just like
pick your poison I happen to think this
ladies and gentlemen you want the U.S to
win more importantly we need to win
politically so he can stop the war but
if a war is going to happen you want the
U.S to win for one simple reason you
live in it and as much as you might
really hate Joe Biden despise his
politics because I certainly don't like
the guy at least you can recognize you
share one thing in common you share a
place like you share like the United
States and so that means as much as
Biden might be selling on selling us out
and being corrupt he doesn't want to
lose his property value so even if that
means on a scale of 1 to 100 with 100
being like shared values and one being
like barely any you have one with Putin
you don't have any Putin some people are
are posting things like oh but he
opposes Satanism and the double
economics no we're not you don't want
Putin to win no Putin is a different
kind of the same bad right of a similar
bad he's another rock in a hard place
yeah he's another politician who's been
in power for how long 22 years many
decades who's looking out for himself
and looking out for his country and his
interests and a counter argument I would
make is that no one's going to win this
war if there's a war no one's winning
this one I'm gonna win you know why
because I got chickens I think I read
somewhere for something pretty
insightful which was that you know we
tend to be very annoyed with like the
Biden and the Democrats hypocrisy when
it comes to this stuff and it's very
frustrating and one thing about Putin is
he's not really a hypocrite he's just
sort of Will To Power you know
straightforward like Yes actually I just
want to conquer your country and I'm
going to do that now rather than sort of
like you know miss you know mixing
messages machinations machinations and
so like there's a tendency for us being
super frustrated with how ridiculous the
Democrats rationalizations can be that
we're just like oh breath of fresh air
somebody who just says what he wants it
but you have to realize like no no no
that's actually you know
that's still that's very very evil and
wrong right like to have this will to
power style of Putin and just conquer
trying to conquer your neighbors but
that's what almost every politician is
essentially if you kind of go down to
the bare minimum of it and uh Putin did
you know it does release a lot of you
know disinformation a lot of propaganda
he does like to confuse people uh he
does uh you know use a lot of different
tactics that the West doesn't usually
deploy
um and I remember seeing I forgot which
documentary this was but it was
describing his strategy of financing his
opponents of creating confusion of of
creating a situation where you weren't
able to fully understand the larger
political ramifications of it but while
everyone is confused and debating he
gets all the power himself I forgot the
documentary that perfectly described
this kind of larger psychological trick
that politicians play on the people
um
I'm going to try to remember as much as
I can that's one yeah I mean that's
that's what possible always do how do
you know a politician's lying he's his
mouth his mouth is moving exactly wait
wait their mouth is moving right
politicians can't be lazy I don't like
this the mouth is moving yeah
politicians aren't people I I don't like
that Vladimir's been in power for 22
years that really upsets me because I
think the point of the Russian
Federation was they were creating some
sort of Democratic Republic I don't know
if they consider themselves a republic
if it's just a federation at this point
whatever that means but he stepped out
and he was gone for a little while and
they said his Lackey was running the
show while he was behind the scenes but
then it's like he came back and at that
time I was like well I think what he's
doing is he's afraid that the liberal
economic order the military war machine
is going to take over the world and he
wants to make sure that it doesn't
happen on his watch and until he's
comfortable that the United States is
the good guys again he's going to be
there protecting Russia but I don't that
doesn't justify Wars of aggression I
don't justify that stuff but it and
maybe it's still that is his methodology
like if I let someone come into power
they're going to be weaker than me
they're going to capitulate and I can't
let that happen hyper normalization is
the term that I was looking for that
describes what I was just saying it was
a part of a BBC documentary from two
thousand 16 and there's a small clip of
it that is absolutely fascinating and
explains what what Putin kind of
mastered but I think is also being
practiced here in the west as well that
I think a lot of people should
understand this larger trickery these
larger psychological tricks played on by
politicians against the people uh hyper
normalization is the word of the day
that you should look up filmed I was
going to say look on the search engine
look on the brave search engine
since the 1970s given up on complex real
world and built a smaller fake world run
by corporations and kept stable by
politicians that's the impetus of the
2016 BBC documentary hyper normalization
and that runs parallel with like the
insurance agencies that the attempting
to take over the world medically and
control you know doctors seven minutes
that they get to spend with their
patients instead of the old
doctor-patient relationship you got
pharmaceutical companies and insurance
agencies trying to run things I just
love how we have commercials where it's
like is flarbestron right for you call
your doctor and I'm like no they cause
death like why would I call my doctor be
like I saw a random ad for a drug I have
no idea what it does but she looked
Happy on the commercial yeah it's like I
don't know yeah and then they're friends
with the insurance salesman rep and then
they like the rep they sell the Reps
drug I think it was Lunesta I think it
was remember Lunesta that's not right
for you and I didn't know what it was
I'm like there's a butterfly it's like
floating around what's happening and I
guess maybe I was too young I think
Rogaine was the first one Rogaine
Rogaine commercials in like the 90s and
they never said what it was in the
commercials I was like what it's the
only commercial I ever saw where they
never said what it was and they just
show people smiling and I was like what
is this it's like Prozac it's like I'm
assuming whatever it is just makes you
happy yeah imagine if they well it is
kind of funny that there's a lot of
drugs that are basically prescription
drugs derivatives and of methamphetamine
salts or just outright opiates and so
they're basically like we're gonna make
opium and heroin illegal but if you get
a prescription of a different form of it
we're going to put a commercial on and I
don't think they actually do commercials
for that stuff though but they certainly
they crank it out through the
pharmaceutical industry I don't know if
we need American constitutionalism for
the future we could have a global
organization where we don't use the
American Constitution and it's much
different it terrifies me to think that
a corporation would Implement its
function onto top-down governance and
you'd have like you know World economic
forum and Pfizer and Johnson and Johnson
and you know Boeing running everyone's
lives that's like I don't like that that
that's why I like this decentralized
kind of autonomy that we've got in the
United States I want to jump to this
story we got from The Daily Mail
Olin starts handing out anti-radiation
tablets as battle rages around Ukraine
nuclear power plant I don't think it's
the nuclear power plant but they do
mention Putin's fresh nuke threat so I
believe this is a potassium iodide yup
potassium iodide tablets okay
first as a PSA to everybody to explain
what this is it's basically iodine what
happens you eat it it goes into your
thyroid when your body absorbs as much
as it can it will reject the rest if
radioactive iodine is in the air or on
the ground or all over the place and
you're eating your body will absorb it
and put radioactive iodine in your
thyroid which then causes problems this
does not protect you from anything else
people seem to think that like if
there's a nuclear bomb that goes off you
take one of these and it protects you
from the radiation like it protects your
thyroid from iodine but there's I mean I
don't know exactly what kind of
radioactive materials are going to be
littered all over the place but
I do want to talk to everybody about the
threat of nuclear war and what it really
means and uh I'll bring up a good story
uh Luke and I we went to Fukushima and
they they told us uh I don't we didn't
take potassium iodide when we went did
we I don't think so no but they gave us
suits and the suits were just cloth
suits and I was kind of like don't you
have to have like some kind of special
material and they're like no no what the
suits do is when the dust and the
particles land on you when you leave you
take it all off so it's not on you and
then you take a shower to wash it all
off and I was like oh okay I thought it
was like for like radiation and they
were like Alpha and beta particles they
stick to you you then eat stuff it gets
in your system
but with Fukushima there was MOX
plutonium and there was iodine 131 or
something like that the MOX plutonium
was a heavy metal lit on the ground it
sinks it drops the iodine kicks up so
you take one of these pills but then you
pick something up off the ground and you
can get some you know MOX plutonium or
whatever it's called on you that ain't
doing anything for you so in the event
of nuclear war the other thing to
consider not every nuclear bomb has a
radioactive yield that's my
understanding is that's intentional
when a bomb goes off and it leaves
radiation like they design it to do that
and there are many nuclear bombs that
actually don't they just do Fireballs so
yeah our understanding of nuclear
weapons is still primitive compared to
the advancements that were made within
what what was it like 90 years 80 years
since the 80s yeah 80 years so so what
we know of the nuclear weapon 80 years
ago is absolutely nothing compared to
what's out there right now and the
technology and the possibilities that
they have Putin and the Russian
government a lot of times talk about
flooding all of the United Kingdom with
a radiation wave and using nuclear
weapons under uh water as a way to start
a tsunami that is going to cover all of
the United Kingdom this is what they
talk about they even made Graphics they
even made a cartoon about this on
Russian State television which is uh
just uh absolutely perplexing and insane
I got a question why would Russia not
have rods from God
um why would they not have why would the
U.S not have that so that's not familiar
it's a theoretical weapon where you put
a uh a series of tungsten rods in a
satellite and it drops them in the force
of gravity it's like more like a hundred
times more powerful than a nuke of the
same size or something yeah some
ridiculous massive explosive yield
um they might who knows I don't know
like I'm not familiar enough with where
technology here's my point it's not it's
not so much about what the technology is
it's that no one even knew they were
building nukes in the first place yeah
there was speculation about this big
project that was going on some thought
that it could be a nuclear weapon some
thought it was going to be a death ray
some thought it was teleportation or
time travel people believed crazy things
and then loan bill turned out to be this
massive explosive device yeah the
Manhattan Project that was uh
spearheaded and started at the Bohemian
Grove of all places where a hundred
thousand people were working on it and
only about two dozen knew exactly what
they were working on right I mean that
said uh I don't know the the way I read
have you read the making of the atomic
bomb by Richard Rhodes no I have a very
very great book by the way when I was
looking into the Bohemian Grove and then
they were just bragging oh the the
nuclear bomb was pretty much created
here and I'm like kind of I mean the the
my understanding based on that book was
that there were a series of experiments
done and publicized in like 1939 1940 in
Germany of all places yep uh where
basically they've I think they split the
uranium atom yeah so uh actually I
upload the Wikipedia discovery of
nuclear fission by German chemists look
at that 1938 how right am I am I right
am I right and then Germany could have
developed the nuclear weapon but they
kicked out their scientists for because
they had a pre they had a religion that
they didn't like and all the scientists
went to the United States and they
started building it here in the United
literally the the Nazis anti-Semitism is
is actually a pretty good argument that
maybe it's not exactly why they lost
World War II but it made their loss
inevitable I mean if Hitler had the
nuclear bomb before anybody else
as well like the development of of
German technology in in the early uh
parts of that world world war were
absolutely just beyond belief you want
to continue with what you're saying that
1940 there so basically but like once
this experiment happened and there were
scientists around the world having seen
this experiment understood the
implication was a nuclear bomb as
possible and so that's you know so
Germany started working on it we started
working on it I think England you know
other countries started working on it
too um so it wasn't when you like I
guess it wasn't a secret at that point
it was sort of if you were in the
scientific Community it was like all the
scientists started talking to the
politicians of like we know this is
possible you should really invest in
this because you don't want the other
guy to get this first because it's just
how much energy was necessarily created
from splitting the uranium atom it was
was enough to make people realize that
it could create a chain reaction on a
bomb and I would even argue you know
Germany Lost World War II but I would
say the Nazis didn't
how so I mean do you mean because Verner
Ron Brown came down one a lot of them
went to Argentina two the Russians and
the Americans scooped them up right
after the war and then had them work on
on NASA had them work on the Russian
space agency what was that was that
paperclip uh yeah Operation Paperclip
and uh the the the the death of Hitler
is still being contested by many
historians there was no body as well so
he could have been in Argentina this
whole time uh Argentina gave them safe
haven and look they did lose that
doesn't mean that's not winning their
influence escaped like I'm making a very
nuanced kind of argument yeah I'm saying
that that the ideology was passed on
through a lot of the top figures being
saved uh through operation pay-per-click
I don't know I mean I wouldn't call
Werner Von Braun like a top Nazi I mean
he was a member of the Nazi party but he
was a rocket scientist right like in
that he didn't that was you know he was
a rocket scientist in Germany
um not saying he wasn't a bad guy or a
good guy I'm just saying like he wasn't
gebels you know some ideologist who's
spreading it and then you look at people
like Eichmann you know was the classic
guy who went to Argentina I mean he he
had to be Incognito for 20 years before
the Israelis finally found him kidnapped
him and tried him in Israel not to
mention there's a bunch of really crazy
stories
um like the uh what is it was it the
istal woman I think it was called I went
to uh there's an amazing story I went to
Bergen Norway a while back and there's
this Legend they have where they found a
woman dead up in the mountain just
outside of town from smoke inhalation
they said and it's been a long time
since I've gone through the story we
interviewed a bunch of people in Bergen
and uh there are like passports outfits
and so one of the leading theories was
that she was Mossad hunting down escaped
Nazis in various countries
and they were being summarily executed
so not escaping but in this instance
this woman was killed by the person she
was sent to assassinate until they found
her body didn't know she was saw a bunch
of aliases and passports never figured
it out but people were like they believe
that Mossad went on for decades probably
even still now are hunting these people
down there there was a story out there
long ago like a guy was like 90
something years old was it like 98 yeah
I heard of that and he was like a Nazi
Garden they found him they arrested yeah
I think they deported him I think there
was a Netflix movie about that I think
it was like a it was like some but
here's what people don't know here's
what people don't understand is that
many of these people who did Escape
probably died within a year from
assassinations and it's not in the news
it's not gonna be in history books a lot
of prominent people are connected to you
know that history whether it's Soros
Arnold Schwarzenegger uh the Canadian
um the minister lady I forgot her name
right now uh but she also has ties to a
lot of that darker kind of history but
uh you know this is something that you
know my people have kind of live through
being from Poland we hear about this all
the time you know this is something that
my family uh you know lost a lot of of
its members to and uh it's still
something that you know I think in
hindsight should be talked about more
especially with the severe escalations
we're seeing in Europe right now that
many people believe is going to prompt
Another World War which is just
absolutely insane yeah Nazism wasn't
stopped the German Third Reich was
stopped but Nazism wasn't it went to is
in eastern Ukraine it still is they call
me azov now the azov Battalion it's like
a Neo-Nazi group wasn't there a picture
of a guy standing with zelenski that had
like the black sun logo or something
yeah it is genuinely true that the
zelenski government is way too friendly
with straight up like Annie seminitz
yeah I mean that was they were roundly I
mean they named one of their major
streets after a guy named Stephan
Bandera yeah who was involved in pogroms
against the Jewish community in advance
of the Germans coming in
um you know and they're all these guys
they're hailing is like Ukrainian Heroes
and Ukrainian nationalists well those
are the guys who like fought the
Russians and sided with the Nazis and
usually we're doing the Nazis bidding
before the Nazi showed up well Ukrainian
is also in a tough position because
that's some of the best fighters that
they have and the Ukrainian government
is like okay let's stop talking about
this because we need to fight a war and
this is how they're kind of excusing it
but they there's a there's a whole I
think a battalion inside of the official
Ukrainian military that was officially
recognized that did have extreme
far-right kind of idea you know ideas
and there's no denying that it's
something that of course the Russians
kind of bring up all the time uh but
this is you know Battalion and a lot of
the stuff gets contested here but but
you're not wrong Ian it's a yeah is is
of regiment uh formed from volunteers
integrated into the National Guard of
Ukraine at least this is what I've been
told is Ezra the azov are the uh the
neo-nazis that's the symbol is like it's
basically a swastika at an angle not a
complete swastika but it's got you know
I don't know if you put yeah there it is
that blue symbol on the right
uh I don't know this is what I hear this
propaganda but I can't imagine being in
the United States and hearing propaganda
that are supposed it's not merely
propaganda like that it there's there's
real truth to that I mean you can look
into
um you know Jewish associations lighting
up the Ukrainian government for their
actions in support of azov and a lot of
their public resurrection of these uh
World War II figures who were uh
anti-semitic another the problem with
war is pushing countries to war is that
the worst I'm not saying that the azov
are the worst but you violent extremists
will rise up to fight because those
might be your best fighters because
they're violent extremists that's what
they do is they know how to fight this
weird like problem for Ukrainian
nationalism in general right because
Ukraine doesn't have this long and deep
history as an independent nation so
they're they're kind of have to reach
for the these figures of nationalist
pride in Ukraine who have these very
very checkered pasts I'd love to see
Ukraine become a neutral territory in
some way like like Switzerland like it's
in it's in a position where it should be
it's like it's like the cerebral
it should have been a buffer state that
would have been much better for
everybody right much better for it's
flat so it's not Ukraine or like a Hong
Kong or like a Singapore but but they're
but Ukraine also has a lot of natural
gas and a lot of uh energy exploration
is being found in that country which
threatens the Russian Petro State and
this is I think another reason why
Russia is being so aggressive especially
in the southern Parts where a lot of
this new energy has been found and will
contest Russia as a petrol State uh and
contend with it directly which of course
Russia can't have because that's one of
its major uh assets is it's energy that
it provides the world oil gas oil energy
yep
so yeah complex situation very confusing
lots of different sides lots of
different atrocities no one wins in war
and and uh please my goodness let's try
to call for some de-escalations here and
stop with this madness and people dying
for the whims of politicians and their
aspirations well we got a we got a
midterm coming up and uh investors.com
Dow Jones drops on hot inflation data so
we're down what uh we're down again
several percentage points what's going
on the Market's imploding we're seeing
real estate prices drop we're seeing
inflation across the board I think food
prices are up in Germany what like night
was it 19 or something or
yeah I don't know something like that
double digits oh it's gonna be bad
um so well so uh aside from the
potassium iodide what kind of emergency
food have you guys about
I cook with a lot of lentils I'm it's
like Ian's cooking lentils every day red
lentils baby this is why it's actually
nice to be in America you know like we
have a lot of food in this country we
don't need to import it we're not in the
position of a lot of countries that do
um you know we we really are blessed by
our Geographic advantages in so many
different ways oh yeah you know oceans
on two sides of us substantially you
know smaller countries on the North and
South good neighbors good neighbors uh
incredible waterways I think somebody
somebody did a map once where they
described the navigable waterways of of
the United States huge mountains that of
course are very difficult to Traverse
sure amazing but you know yeah I mean so
and you can build stuff in them like
underground bases that's right well that
can withstand nuclear I'm just saying
there's there's so much natural Farmland
in the United States it's just dwarfs
almost anywhere else in the world in
terms of just the amount out of farmland
and the ability yeah a lot of country to
produce its own food yeah and uh we
don't we don't have to buy cat food
actually because bocus just caught a
squirrel the other day and we couldn't
again no I just thought I'm talking
about the one that he got and he he went
into one of the ramps we couldn't get
him out and I guess he just ate it so
you know well there's that that's cheap
when you live out here in the middle of
nowhere man you can uh you can grow your
own food it's pawpaw season guys you
know we we had a pawpaw bread today it
was amazing oh good Papa's hillbilly
banana
so uh there's food aplenty but if you
live in a big city like New York or even
outside of one like I don't know
Arlington for instance you're probably
in trouble especially with the potential
attacks on infrastructure so if energy
goes out if the internet goes out which
again a lot of it is dependent on
underground cables which I think we
should be keeping a close eye on because
I do believe there's supposed to be some
significance that can be that's a
logical way for Russia to retaliate
against us that's very logical you're
going to be watching your house of
dragons and it's going to cut off yeah
and then it's going to be like we can't
load because Russia cut a cable
come on
or you can't have an energy I mean if
you can't have energy or Communications
in a place like New York City I mean
you're screwed people people don't
understand how how spoiled we've gotten
I want you to imagine this scenario
you're sitting in your house when all of
a sudden the power goes out
cell lines are down your phone doesn't
work you can't text anybody you have no
internet it's just you and your family
you live let's say you live in a small
suburban community
all of a sudden you know it's a couple
hours you're talking to neighbors like
what's going on we don't know military
vehicles pull up
next time you're lucky they tell you get
everybody line up line up what do you do
you have no idea who they are you have
no idea what's going on do you just say
yes what if it's the enemy what if
something serious what if they took out
a substation what if they've invaded
what do you do well I would say if the
military shows up in a situation like
that comply because it's probably the
good guys if they show up right away
um
look at them if they have American
insignias on them don't fight them
they're probably there to help it's
probably a National Guard coming out if
something really bad happens but you
know obviously don't just learned
nothing when the men just don't don't
don't you know don't think Don't Go full
paranoia Insane Mode right away if
something bad happens you know keep your
wits about you and remember that we're
on American soil we're all here together
when your power and Communications go
down and a military vehicle pulls up no
don't comply demand confirmation yeah
but I mean don't be so don't know what
it is basically is what I'm saying like
like just be leave and then let be uh
you know you don't have to comply you
don't have to go along with with
whatever military you might show up at
your door want you to do is it an
assessment of like what the odds are
whether they're friendly or enemy
military yeah I mean obviously the odds
are it's a friendly military
or if there's like a coup d'etat exactly
but that'll be in DC right yeah but that
will happen it's not even about that
it's about they've rounded Americans up
before and put them in camps right in
World War II this happened but even even
I mean don't just say it sure all get on
the bus well but like should should the
Japanese have you know violently
resisted the efforts of that have been
smart for the Japanese it could be
peacefully and passively resisted at the
very least I don't know I just I think
it you know it's one of those like
horrible things but the outcomes for the
Japanese people who resisted would not
have been better than those that
complied like it's an appalling a human
rights abuse by our government but that
doesn't mean that like the correct and
practical course of action for the
victims of that oppression was to
violently I'm not sure at the same time
the appropriate response is to willfully
enter a concentration camp no no don't
just jump into the fire when you see it
burning but you know use discretion and
don't just assume it's the enemy of
something you don't have to resist you
don't have to comply either but but you
know you could you could force the issue
and make it more of a debate yeah sure
you could definitely make it like some
sort of like civil decision
we're talking about overt violations of
the Constitution like and civil rights
and humans criminal actions being placed
being made against the American citizens
because they were scared at some of them
because of the way they looked may have
been spots in hindsight if you were
Japanese during World War II what would
you do
I don't know that's a like it I'm trying
to I think that I would try and avoid
detection by the guy well right I would
try and avoid it I wouldn't I don't
think I'd like start shooting at
government agents to yeah avoid being
taken to a to one of the camps but I
think I would try and like of you know
I'd try and avoid them Hide You Wanna of
course try to go through everything
before resorting to violence uh you want
to try all options
Disobedience protesting but like it's a
difficult question what should the Jews
in Germany have done
uh different I mean different given that
the I mean and I think the Warsaw
Uprising demonstrates this right like
the way that in it was a there is a
category difference between how we
treated the Japanese people and how the
Nazis treated Jews right yeah genus you
know the camps versus genocide is a big
big goal a lot of a lot of the the the
Jewish people and it wasn't just Jewish
people it was it was Polish people it
was gay people a lot of these
handicapped people a lot of gypsies they
weren't beaten and dragged into some
into these train cards many of them were
just they pulled up and said all right
you know we're getting in we're bringing
you to a camp well a lot of them were
also work camps like my family got sent
to a work camp and then they had death
camps as well so uh my my
great-grandmother was in a war camp with
my grandmother my grandmother tells me
the stories and and the craziness of
that situation and uh you know she was
extremely lucky and randomly a a family
just decided to pick her up after her
her mother my great-grandmother was sent
off to death camp and she died there and
uh a family adopted my grandmother and
that's the only reason she she survived
that's the only reason I'm here today
they went to a work camp and picked her
up in Poland when the German government
took over during World War II if you had
a number of kids you didn't have to pay
taxes
um and and the state liked that you had
a number of kids because you were
procreating so there was a family that
didn't have enough kids to not pay taxes
didn't have enough kids to to get the
government benefits so they adopted one
off of one of the trains that was
heading off to the stuttoff camp and
that's where you know my
great-grandmother passed away so in
hindsight you know I mean it's something
people should consider Luke was born in
a Soviet satellite yeah I was like this
stuff my family took part in the in the
salad protest that of course was a big
part of taking down communism a big part
of taking down the Soviet Union so now
people know where he gets it from well
yeah absolutely you know you're raised
in this stuff and you have your family
tell you hey this happened to your uncle
this is the torture that he went through
hey this is the the secret jail the
secret you know this is the craziness
that we faced this here then and then
and then and you keep hearing these
stories and it's just absolutely
um you know it it it it it it builds who
you are because it teaches you the
important lessons of history that sadly
a lot of people have forgotten and this
is why I'm so passionate about these
issues this is why I've been at this for
so long because the writing is on the
wall and I think it's only a matter of
time until we we repeat history and I
think in many instances we already have
you mentioned Communications being part
of uh the danger of loss of electricity
all that in New York or whatever but
like so would it be wise for people then
to get CB radios with like a solar solar
charger or something it would probably
get that for 100 bucks a regular AM FM
radio yeah 28 bucks hand crank you ever
see those you you can crank it to charge
the battery yeah yeah get one of those
exhausting you charge for a while but it
works but you you want to hear what's
going on because they may say you'll
turn the radio on and it'll say A large
group of whatever are heading down
heading south down I-90 as leave the
area now you you know it's estimated
they'll arrive within one hour and then
you're gonna be like okay it's time to
get out of here yeah two-way radio too
that's that'll if the internet goes yeah
that's the kind of stuff that's
happening in Ukraine I'm sure yeah like
or happened especially during uh Jimmy
advances I I mean people just don't get
it all right imagine you're in your
neighborhood imagine there's shooting
going on in every direction
you walk outside
it's cold do you wear a coat yes or no
yeah you get shot oh right because
someone sees you they don't know what
you're carrying they say don't know
don't care I'm not taking the risk when
there's active conflict going on this so
This is actually what's something that
happened to guy I think it was like a
civilian was walking down the street
someone shot him because they were like
the coat was big they couldn't tell if
he was armed or not and they didn't want
to take a risk because there's Russian
and Ukrainian forces fighting you see a
random guy you say you want to risk it
you want to be the one to walk over them
and make sure that he's on your side or
not or would you rather just sweep the
area with your team you know you can
trust and say screw it to everybody else
people don't get what war is like I'm
not going to pretend to have been in it
I've been in civil unrest and and some
civil conflict and even then it's crazy
the craziest thing about it is how
normal things continue this is what
really bugs me about the whole Civil War
narrative
when uh Scott Adams and and you know uh
Bill Burr were like go outside nobody's
fighting Scott Adams said there's not
going to be a civil war you know how I
know right and then and then he said
there's there's no there's no appetite
for outside of Twitter's imagination and
someone responded how do you know he
said what's your Source he said I went
outside yes I've I've been uh I was in
Kiev during the year of my Dan protests
there were riots there were police it
was getting crazy they were tense and
then you walk two blocks and you're at a
shopping center in fact the shopping
center was in the maidan Square so like
you could walk from the protests where
there had been people firebombing tanks
or apcs and you could walk inside and
I'm gonna buy uh I'm gonna buy this coat
right here in this this shopping in
Egypt during the revolution you could
walk two blocks from Tahira square and
that's a McDonald's with people eating
cheeseburgers and they're watching the
game in the Hilton Hotel
you could walk in while people this is
the craziest thing I'm on the 26th floor
looking down people are throwing things
at each other they're shooting each
other it was too warning it was it was
two rival factions secular group and the
Muslim Brotherhood APC start rolling
through with people riding on top
they're hooting and hollering I walk 10
feet and there's a casino people are
playing games and acting like nothing is
happening people seem to think that when
War breaks out it's everyone running
around flailing throwing things and
screaming people still have to live
stores try to operate sometimes it gets
so bad that the bullets stop people from
doing it
but if you've if you know you look at
these videos out of Syria and there are
people walking down the street carrying
like a basket full of fruits while
there's like shelling going on what are
they supposed to do they got to eat
humans still have to do these things the
best the craziest thing when the war in
Syria broke out we tried pursuing the
story while advice the Damascus tourism
board was advertising for people even in
the United States to come party and
enjoy the nightlife of Damascus when
they were like fears of sarin gas
attacks and so we were like we were
advice and we're like can we do this
like can we go to Damascus and film a
video that's literally just us partying
and entertaining what they're what
they're advertising while acknowledging
this war is going on so you're saying
you don't shut down for war but maybe
for a virus sometimes I don't get it
what's worse here uh you know shout out
to Elon Musk and starlink and anyone
else that's working on satellite
internet because of our terrestrial
internet does go down which it sounds
extremely vulnerable if it's underwater
and cables right along where those
pipelines run they just got one of those
we need you know a backup and if we got
internet satellites then at least we'll
be able to keep talking to each other I
think that we can maintain order in a
blackout there's a satellite
Communications two-way texting devices
they're only a couple hundred bucks
I recommend it yes satellite internet's
getting a lot better that's why that's
why WI-Fi is a lot better on planes the
new iPhones have satellite uh as well
yep the new iPhones if you get lost and
there's no cell phone service you could
literally use the iPhone as a way to
track down satellites as a way to send
out an SOS signal and reach search and
rescue anywhere and everywhere
yes SOS via satellite yeah that's
impressive yeah so I mean yeah so 10
years ago I was doing a buddy of mine
was doing security Consulting I was
assisting him he was a security guy I
wasn't but you know I know a little bit
about infosex stuff and Tack and drones
but one of the things that he got was a
two-way texting device that allows you
to send text messages it's this little
gray box I'd have to imagine 10 years
later the technology is vastly improved
so that's really cool and now it's in
your cell phone the new iPhone 14. well
he's got one great yeah it's not even
the phone it's in it's in the software
update right like I think my phone which
is a 13. I remember seeing that I'm not
an SOS sure because it's a new antenna
that they're using to link with the
satellite it might you might be right
but I don't I'm not done I don't know my
phone suggests I think my phone suggests
it because like when I'm out when I have
no bars I see SOS and I'm like that
takes over a minute to send under trees
with light or medium footage that's
crazy if you're in ideal conditions you
have a view of the sky and the Horizon
it'll take 15 seconds to send oh my gosh
it's just an SOS call you don't get to
send tech can you send text well you
send information about what's going on
here and you go through the prompts
especially 14. okay yeah it says well it
it is coming with an update but it says
using emergency SOS via your iPhone okay
here I guess you have to you have to
have an iPhone 14. yeah wow I actually
want to get one now I mean imagine
you're hiking and you get lost yeah
that's really that's just hold it up and
just wait for a minute and then they're
gonna get a GPS coordinate then you just
bunker down right wow yep
cool stuff modern technology that's
awesome yeah it can be used to track you
everywhere you go probably they're
probably completely probably a back door
in there that of course is Like
Satellites we can't see what he's saying
send in the satellites but it gives you
the chance to track yourself which is
pretty cool yeah I do they gotta this
software should be free for sure now
there's no escaping the the the DARPA
dark net and the surveillance system
well the worrying thing is that
technology has eventually become
Necessities luxuries become Necessities
so what happens is in 20 years you're
walking through a forest there's a you
know a guy drive you know Park a Park
employee or a park ranger pulls up and
he goes you didn't register on the
beacon system where's your uh where's
your GPS it's like I don't have one
put your hands behind your back but I'm
from 2021 let me go where's your
permission slip to be in nature which is
what they're doing more and more
efficiently you literally need
permission slip to go into a lot of
national parks and you need to make
reservations sometimes years in advance
it's absolutely crazy that the
government is limiting people's ability
to be in nature and that's just um I
want to use some French language here
but I won't uh absolutely wrong that's
funny the criminal French when people
start swearing up a storm they're like
that's French man I love them shout out
to the French man and the statue all
right let's talk about Elon Musk
so uh for those that don't know Elon
musk's text messages have been uh
released not all of them but many of
them I love this one and uh some of them
are like really silly like what is what
is this I jump on a grand for you like I
jump on a grand for you well this this
is what happens when someone's had an
iPhone and then they like your text
Android users see this weird ridiculous
message again I get it I'll say
something like you know like oh man I'm
I'm feeling sick and it'll be like liked
oh man I'm feeling sick and I'm like
thanks for letting me know I guess but
I'm like Dad when you're just tapping it
so uh will what's what's going on here
Elon Musk is apparently gonna have to
buy Twitter what's the deal I mean yeah
so the litigation's ongoing remember
that Twitter sued Elon Musk to try and
make him buy the company and go through
with his merge with the merger agreement
I mean and I've predicted for quite some
time that Elon is going to lose this
lawsuit and he's gonna be forced by
Twitter uh the trial is coming up in a
couple weeks but anyway the reason we're
seeing all this stuff is because right
now they're in doing this like really
Rush Discovery process and everybody
he's producing everything including all
of elon's text messages with people that
relate in any way to the Twitter buyout
and so
some of these are absolutely hilarious
like there was a whole text conversation
I think I sent it to the group here's
one from um who is this
oh this is with Jason calacanas what's
going on with you marketing and spv2
randos this is not okay not randos I
have the largest Angel Syndicate that's
how I invest blah blah blah yeah so what
are some of the good ones oh the good
ones are one the wood this one with
Prague so Prague I think I put this in
the Twitter group chat uh parag is the
CEO of Twitter yeah he says yeah
Progressive CEO Twitter he says you are
free to tweet quote is Twitter dying end
quote or anything else about Twitter but
it's my responsibility to tell you that
it's not helping me make Twitter better
in the current context next time we
speak I'd like to provide you with
perspective on the internal distraction
how it's causing it blah blah blah Elon
response what did you get done this week
I'm not joining the board this is a
waste of time we'll make an offer to
take Twitter private also this is why I
like Elon and yeah zero to 100 imagine
talking to someone like paraga yeah like
that the way he talked it's just I'd be
like come on guys say words let's let's
let's figure out what you need to get
done that you don't like there's two
typos in in Prague response I'd like to
you provide you perspective and then on
the level of internal distraction right
now and how it hurting our ability to do
work like he's the CEO of Twitter and he
gets two typos in a message to Elon Musk
who wants to spend 54 billion dollars
but a guy can't get his his text right
like right dude
I would I would be also be very annoyed
if I got a text like that from someone
that was purported to be a CEO yeah
check your text yeah I think I mean it
does show that sort of the decision to
take go and take Twitter private was a
little bit emotional on like elon's part
and kind of impulsive yeah he probably
regretted it on yeah he probably and I
think that's I mean that's the heart of
a lawsuit is that you know you just have
buyer's remorse like you you just
suddenly realize the value tanked you
know well not that the value tank but he
thought he saw a General market downturn
coming and the the amount of money that
it was going to take to buy Twitter was
just too big a portion of his net worth
and would have too many implications on
Tesla and and SpaceX yeah that and
Twitter's you know trash yeah but I
don't know I think I mean that was never
why Elon really wanted to buy it I don't
think I mean he always said it wasn't an
economic rationale and I I heard that I
think that I I got a question what is
what does Elon care about his net worth
you know I I mean it I mean I understand
wanting to build stuff but I mean it
implicates his ability to continue to
control what happens it tells for
example because most of his net worth is
bound up in Tesla stock so I guess it
would take too much of his stock right
so we'd have to sell too much of it the
value would go down his his overall
control of Tesla might decrease I'm not
exactly sure if Tesla operates with the
you know Class A Class B shares that
always means this is this is a question
you know here's a question right you
know I've spent a long time working on
this this YouTube channel as long as as
well as many other people and my other
show uh podcast on my other YouTube
channels and it's like would I sacrifice
these if it meant I got to own Twitter
and then shut Twitter down
and I'm kind of like I mean I could be I
think ultimately Twitter's going to be a
better business than Tesla frankly well
Tesla's working on a lot of things like
personalized robots I don't know if you
heard about this one they might be but
I'm still I mean I their basic business
is is car manufacturing and and car
manufacturing is a terrible business
it's just a super Capital intensive I
mean every other car manufacturer in the
World trades at like a price to earnings
ratio of six or something which is just
way below and the government's not
giving him any subsidies they're giving
it to a lot of other yeah so uh it's
just it's just I think you know being an
auto manufacturer is actually a really
rough and hard business there's a reason
Tesla was like a few years ago was like
nearly going bankrupt and why a lot of
the big manufacturers go to Mexico or
China oh yeah and I mean think about all
the constant bankruptcies you hear about
GM and Ford and I mean it's super
competitive too that's the other thing I
mean elon's not the only guy making
electric cars there's a billion other
manufacturers coming out with them so I
look at Twitter Twitter's kind of got
this almost Monopoly on this particular
type of Public Square communication it's
just a question of how to monetize it
but you know compare like all the
Twitter competitors are getting wrecked
it's not the same in car manufacturers
where there's a lot of effective
competition Mize doesn't have a lot of
overhead which is a big upside like
Twitter's got I don't know 5 000
employees sure ridiculous amount of
money you spend on that I don't even
know what they're doing but it's fire
remote but like I mean think about what
happened to parlor right like parlor I
don't know if you saw there was actually
a small news item but the new Power CEO
basically said they're they're pivoting
away from their legacy social media
business into like servers for the you
know trying to can you know similar to
rumble create like the uncancelable
economy
um gabs is getting wrecked right and so
the idea is that the you know Client
Services yeah so there I mean basically
that's that's the CEO of parlor or the
new CEO parlor looking at it and like
wow this social media business is not
going anywhere I'm going to do something
else uh Jason is he still the CEO the
new CEO the new seat you know Jason left
I think it's it's Candace Owens husband
is the news no of parlors George farmer
yeah parlor and getter and gab and it's
like oh yeah get her get her I mean
getter's just funded by the Chinese like
billionaire the guy who funds Bannon I
thought he was bankrupt I don't think
he's bankrupt but that's where the like
that the original funny yeah Jason
Miller of getter is what I was talking
about and he's still CEO see that's the
thing I got parlor and get her mixed up
like they're both ER Twitter get her
parlor like they're just copying carbon
like and what's the difference here
it's no e just the consonant and then
the r the only way they're trying to
compete like their entire competitive
Advantage is we don't censor but that's
not really a competitive Advantage like
they're Pro I mean and the end result of
that is I mean if if you're you get the
the core of your user base then becomes
the people who were censored I don't
even know why people use Twitter I don't
know I mean I like I like Twitter and
Twitter's where everybody else is so
it's still the functional Public Square
I think yeah this is one of those
Twitter and this particular type of
social media business is just it's a
natural monopoly Elon he needs to buy it
man yeah because he's so much better we
need we need Alex Jones back we need
Carl Benjamin back we need milianopoulos
back we need Laura Loomer back should be
on there they should be saying what they
think and being they should be allowed
to say yeah I mean just settle dude
you're gonna lose anyway he's gonna lose
this lawsuit settled by the company
maybe that's the idea is
he's going to get it cheaper now just by
forcing a settlement maybe but we're I
mean we're you know he's close we're
close to a trial in an order from the
judge that says yeah Elon you're you you
are ordered to buy the company at this
price wow what if he can't he can't he
has the money like and everybody knows
he has that I mean that you can do
public based on his public Holdings of
you know Tesla can they force
liquidation of Tesla stock oh yeah yeah
wow and hold them in contempt well
basically they can hold him in contempt
until he does it and charge it and is
find him enough money that effectively
enforces it yeah I think I think you
said this before that uh a judge can
hold you in contempt in a way that's
that's reasonable to make you comply
right meaning like if you're very
wealthy they will just make it painful
for you right there there's there's no
limit to the amount they can find you if
if you're just in content flouting in a
court order right they're they're going
to do as much as is necessary to get you
to comply did you guys see the Jack
Dorsey Elon Musk texts are those also
from Discovery yeah yeah it's like I
have it all here but there's like no way
I'm gonna be able to go through it yeah
there's better formats I've seen of it
CNBC did a story on it Jack Dorsey tried
to get Eli but it's them talking about
basically that they want to they both
want to decentralize the the technology
and uh work together and the Jack was
like I couldn't I could try and get you
on the board I got three percent of the
company and really no pull there but
I'll see what I can do and then these
like what I really want to do is use
this stuff as a decentralized protocol
anyone's was like okay I like that idea
so if he buys Twitter uses the software
freeze the software code makes it like a
universal Global effort to create a
decentralized encrypts private messages
so for sure to anyone well the downside
of encrypted messages if I send you
something encrypted you can send that to
anyone I don't have any like I gotta you
gotta trust the person on the other end
but the idea is it's encrypted between
the two people yeah that are using the
message yeah yeah
encrypted messaging is key so how do you
think this is going to play out how do
you see this kind of going forward
what's the timeline and then uh do you
see a a big kind of blowback if Elon
does take over that there might be some
efforts because Bill Gates already had a
lot of secretive efforts with his uh
organizations trying to of course attack
Elon Musk they had a big public beef he
used a lot of his ngos as a form to
attack him will there be attacks on
Twitter to of course compromise it as a
platform I mean I don't know if they can
really compromise it as a platform I
think you'll see the activists will be
in a different position where because
Elon won't pay attention to the
left-wing activists in the same way that
the current management does what I'm
speculating is what if someone says okay
well Elon has the platform now let's
talk about how many Bots are on the
platform oh it's it's 50 of the platform
but it's a private company so it's not
subject to the same sort of security
manipulation but someone could leak or
or try to of course sabotage the company
yeah I mean maybe but it's it the the
sort of obvious methods of sabotage that
you're thinking of wouldn't work in the
world where it's a private company and
then it doesn't have to obey Securities
laws in the same way right where it's
you know the it's it's one of the big
disciplining things about our system and
and I think people you know we think
that the free market and capitalism only
you know works because of competition
but one big thing is that public company
CEOs have to tell the truth about their
companies every three months in a way
that politicians don't yeah you know
politicians can just lie and lie and lie
about the operation of the government
and so can the department heads and
nobody goes nobody's ever you know
threatened to jail for that but if you
are a public company CEO and you lie
about your business results you can go
to jail for Securities fraud but why
don't we make it so that whenever you're
inaugurated or whatever you swear uh an
oath to you know tell the truth well
it's like it's it's like the government
the problem is it's the government
trying to hold itself accountable for
honesty and especially like the highest
level officials and it just doesn't it
doesn't work the same way the reason
this works is because the sovereign is
imposing that discipline on on public
company CEOs I remember uh James Clapper
testifying under oath that they weren't
wittingly spying on the American people
with the prism software or the prism
program and they were but I mean in the
user used the word wittingly like maybe
they were inadvertently doing it and
didn't realize it but I mean I think
they were kind of wittingly spying and
like no there was no yeah you know
there's these external consequences
right like even James Clapper should
have been prosecuted but I mean you
can't the intelligence agencies have the
own their own problem which is like the
the ultimately the Jade group Hoover
problem they know too much yeah lying to
Congress you know that's a charge that's
being thrown around right now Hoover did
that routinely exactly
you know individuals like Roger Roger
Stone get charged for that other
individuals like the former head of the
CIA that knowingly lie that also get us
into Wars no no no it's weird I'm gonna
use that one it's like the the
industrial agriculture of politics is
like or what do you call it when they
have a bunch of like Pig slaughterhouses
in secret we don't want to look at it we
don't want to smell it but we know those
pigs are getting cut up in like tens by
tens of thousands people are grabbing
piglets and smashing them on the ground
because they don't like them like crazy
people working these Slaughter shops we
know it's happening a lot of people do
but we're just letting it happen because
we want that bacon we know the CIA is
lying but we just let it happen because
it's the we need a Secret Agency telling
lies for a living like that's the whole
point of the CIA I don't know if you can
compare the CIA to bacon you know bacon
has a purpose yeah bacon actually helps
people I have begging every morning and
it may it like it's the light of my day
I'll tell you more about it I just
started the CIA book and I'm going to
read more about it what is it called
it's called let me see a legacy of Ashes
sounds about right yeah which is really
I mean I think is that from the JFK
quote I'm not sure JFK had a famous
quote about what he wanted to do with
the CIA oh yeah yeah yeah and
um
it was like I'll tell you what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna tear them up set him on
fire and then piss on them there's a
really great xcia uh former CIA counter
terrorist expert Kevin Shipp and I
highly recommend looking up anything he
does on the internet he he wrote a book
called from the company of Shadows
talking about CA operations abuse of
secrecy and he's like full out they
threatened his family he said since he's
left and talked about it but he's like
just straight up and telling you there's
like a law they have that lets them lie
it almost encourages for the name of
National Defense standard protocol what
was uh Mike pompeo's uh he said you know
we were taught to lie cheat and steal
and that's exactly what we did some he
said something to that tone I forgot
what it was I gotta pull it up
yeah but I've just I also finished him
same guy Tim weiner wrote a book called
enemies which was about the FBI that's
also a really good book I've sort of
been you know read about the FBI and the
CIA since we're all talking about fixing
him
um fixing yeah right dismantling
um but yeah no CIA see the big thesis of
CI the CIA book so far is the CIA is
actually incompetent like we think of it
as scary and over you know abusive but
in real you know the big lesson is more
than anything it was just straight up
incompetent it killed a lot of its own
agents for no good reason well I would
argue that's a cover but that's just my
own pure speculations but Mike Pompeo
did say on the record quote we lied we
cheated we stole we had entire training
courses it reminds you of the glory of
the American experiment that's literally
what he said
um and now he might be running uh to be
the next president of the United States
the glory of the American experiment
meaning like stealing the land from the
native population
Ah that's you know like telling them you
know we're gonna we're gonna make a deal
with you and then not giving them this
stuff I mean there's a well I think it
was known as the natives would would
give their land for like blankets and
then they wanted the land back and
they're like no you call that they call
it Indian giver it was like this real
offensive you know I'm not uh they still
call them Indian like they're from India
I'm not an expert in Indian history but
I know there's a lot of contention to
what actually happened Indian history is
in India the Native American population
that was abuse of slander to call those
people Indians especially if they knew
they didn't land in India and they knew
that really early on I think actually a
lot of them don't care well I care but
you call Indians Indian call Native
Americans Americans
that's my opinion I think that whatever
we gotta jump to the story my friends
it's the end of an era Trevor Noah quits
The Daily Show after wokery saw viewing
figures slumped to around 363 363
000 a show seven years we're taking over
from Jon Stewart who routinely pulled in
an audience of 1.5 million yeah I do
think wilkry played a role but I also
think it's just a change in how media is
being consumed I think Jon Stewart was
the real talent Trevor Noah was kind of
a nobody so he couldn't really pull
anything in yeah and also who's going to
be watching this year Jon Stewart built
that show Trevor Noah just inherited it
uh but this is but this is still good
news yes I think Trevor Noah was was bad
he had half truths and misinformation
consistently on his show that he
wouldn't fact check and uh these are the
kind of people that believed Russia gate
Ukraine gate hands up don't shoot Ahmed
Aubry you know the Trayvon Martin stuff
they believed all the lies the
manipulations
so seeing him go
I was talking about this earlier
it is the end of an era the corporate
establishment the woke establishment
they are dwindling James Corden is that
his name that guy he's out yeah canceled
she's out did Gordon quit I think he
quit uh Trevor Noah quit he is quitting
he has he's not out yet but he's
announced his departure from the show
and so good there who are they going to
get this is effectively the end of this
of this trash Jon Stewart may have had
something back in the day but he created
this breed of mechanical formulaic fake
political humor that has plagued this
country for a decade so I'm glad to see
Trevor Noah out hopefully things like
this start to spread out and downturn
hopefully there's more of this I mean
you think about Jon Stewart destroyed
Crossfire you remember that that's right
right and Crossfire at the time he was
like this is partisan hackery we can do
so much better and it's like Crossfire
was the last time you had Republicans
and Democrats regularly debating each
other on equal terms
Jon Stewart comes in smug as a button
and says this is garbage and mock stock
Carlson and what does what is Jon
Stewart's Legacy garbage formulaic trash
humor you get it John Oliver it's the
current year little Timothy yes it's
like it's it's only it's not just that
it's that somebody uh somebody actually
wrote out the formula for John John
Oliver's Show and it was like say thing
compare it to thing in the past say what
year it is then say Timothy and it was
like you're like wow he actually does
that like half the time that's crazy and
then it was like they mentioned there
would be beats with claps from the
audience like and it was his meme that
was talking about how this was basically
programming people say thing call it
absurd whether it's true or not tell the
audience to clap for it
that's John Stewart's Legacy Samantha B
all that stuff gone good yeah and it was
it's all been terrible like Jon Stewart
was like the original and I remember Jon
Stewart being pretty funny at times like
he actually had real talent but God the
derivatives of Jon Stewart were so bad
The Echoes of Stuart yeah The Colbert
Report plague horror I thought it was so
bad he was pretending to be a war monger
and you couldn't tell if he was being
honest or not it was the worst he was
being a warmonger yeah he was basically
like well that's why we need war and
you're like is he people don't
understand you're joking bro like that
was a you you program people for a
decade have you watched his show I
nearly vomited for like 10 years
he wants his money and he'll hide behind
you know whoever's John Stewart Jon
Stewart's Legacy is a plague on this
country
It Like Jordan klepper is his name or
whatever Samantha B John Oliver Stephen
Colbert these are not good people
helping them you're the only good alumni
of The Daily Show or the people who went
into acting like Steve Carell that's it
right right yeah he avoided political he
avoided the political stuff and he just
did the office and was and it's been
funny for a decade I mean Colbert was
funny on The Daily Show when he was the
correspondent I thought he's a funny
actor but his political crap is like
just oh yeah I thought Colbert Report is
better than was better than uh the
current version of Colbert's late night
show which is just pure like the most
banal thing ever when Jon Stewart went
on Colbert's show the new one and said
that lab leak was the most likely
scenario for coven and Colbert was
pushing back like no no no no no no and
that contrast right there was the
difference between what Jon Stewart
started and what beat what his legacy is
right that's true and you know he was
very busy also dancing with the syringes
so uh he was preoccupied and couldn't
really think straight there but you know
who who thought you know just being a
show for The Establishment wasn't paying
off and I think
a big reason to to why this this is
happening is because probably Comedy
Central is running out of money and I
think they're going to move into the
same realm as yeah do they have anything
now I mean I guess they have South Parks
they have reruns of South Parks I guess
they don't even get original which are
now Premier premiered originally on on
Paramount plus uh so even even Comedy
Central doesn't have that so they're
probably going to be running just reruns
of old shows Tosh.0 uh and just like
they have just like apple and Jon
Stewart I mean Comedy Central was like
the cable network absolutely yes and it
pushed the limit yeah especially with
Chappelle it pushed the Overton window
and it was able to have a conversation
that that was pretty spicy and wild you
know what this photo is compliance Daily
Show audience and what do you notice
about it masks what year is it yeah it's
2022 little Timothy take off your mask
what is going on with the daily shows
audience that they're all still doing
this and they're not laughing they're
clipping and it's a cult yeah
yeah it is
they they they're they're not following
the guidelines anymore they're in their
own weird cult yo the mass mandates are
gone what are you doing what's going on
man it's been almost two it's been oh
it's been over a year they're still
doing it it's crazy
well congratulations Jon Stewart you
know he he has come back and he's he
dabbled in wokeness and stuff now too
because he people are just desperate for
relevance I guess I mean it must be said
you know there's a lot of people who are
in say the music industry and they get a
handful of hit songs then the next album
comes out and it's like it sells
decently the next album comes out and no
one really cares and then their next
album comes out and it sells literally
nothing and they get dropped by their
label these people lost it they're so
desperate and scared that you offer them
anything they'll take it so reality TV
dancing with the chef it's like okay
you're gonna dance and this guy's gonna
cook food at the same time like I'll do
anything please I want to be famous the
natural trajectory of a internet come
here Harvey Weinstein like I said loudly
to his candidates the modern Superstar
does different things you don't keep
doing what made you famous when you were
young you got to go on to the next thing
make some hit songs make a hot TV show
learn Russian learn how to cook maybe
start a bread Baking Company like you've
got to do new things you can't back in
the day they just recycle the same
garbage but then they get unhappy and
then they start just playing the game to
play the game and they get lazy so you
really got to Branch Out and because the
reason you can do that is because all
the tools are at your fingertips you can
learn Russian tonight you can start
baking you have access to every food on
Earth essentially right now well a lot
of people do I'm very lucky to have
access to every food on Earth right now
with a lot of them so you may or may not
I don't know but if you know you can
that's not true look up ingredients
online you can look up recipes you can
start baking tonight there's so many
never been easier to learn to cook I
will say that you can't get wasabi yeah
most of it is scandalous I think it's
like you can only get it actually in
Japan they don't so we what we have is
like a weird I'm being hyperbolic with
every food on Earth but you have a wide
variety of foods to choose from and
recipes available at your fingertips
languages you can you can learn how to
pile it with flight simulators like
right now you can start learning the
basics and then go take your pilot's
exam you're making me hungry I want some
wagyu beef hungry for flight you made me
think about Japan bake with some vinegar
baby well you've not been here you just
you know I'm just waiting for that bacon
to come in so we ran out of the the
pre-wrapped bacon I had to order more
but it takes you know a week or so to
come the reason that came to my mind is
like if Jon Stewart did learn Russian
and went to Russia and started talking
to is it like a diplomat now we're
talking International superstardom again
and he doesn't have to like hang on to
Stephen Colbert's coattails to try and
stay relevant and like say that the new
cool thing
but it takes a lot of effort to learn
new things you know there's no reason
that Jon Stewart couldn't actually be a
very interesting figure if he just
dispensed with the wokeness because I
don't think that's really him that
wasn't him in the 2000s at all he
praised project Veritas on more than one
occasion yeah you know and he criticized
people even Barack Obama and his drone
strikes which was rare and he broke from
the norm so whenever you see someone
trying to be accepted and be liked
that's just a disgusting behavior that
naturally human beings are like okay
this is fake this is ingenuine I don't
like any of this get away from me but
when someone's being themselves and
willing to push you know the envelope
and willing to be themselves and willing
to actually speak truth to power that's
respectable that's something that people
you know really love because it
resonates with them and it's rare but it
also helps progress society and make
Society better when you're willing to of
course get out of the agenda get out of
the narrative and be able to actually
have a real honest conversation and stop
bullshitting people about all this
nonsense that of course is all a part of
an agenda meant to enslave Humanity
so yeah that's just my opinion at the
last time
my little aspect there was just
conjecture there for for me but but you
get the point this is the story I think
is is a white pill moment it's optimism
you know so I mentioned this uh at the
start of the show I did a segment on
this earlier the day uh earlier in the
day and I mentioned that we are going to
have one of the towers on New Year's Eve
so it's a substantial amount of
advertisement there's I think 10 ads
that rotate over 100 seconds we'll have
one of those sets they're all
synchronized it's going to be amazing
and everybody who's watching the
celebration is going to see that ad
because they're they're playing a
celebration all day so it's just all day
all over the world everyone tuning into
New York City we are taking that space
over I don't see The Daily Show up there
you got to do a thing where it's just a
beanie and then you slowly materialize
into it and then you're there I mean
that'd be cool but I don't know if it
would like send an effective message to
me man that'd be awesome I guess I was
thinking like you know one marketing
strategy would be to go weird by just
doing like using every every screen to
show Roberto Jr because then people are
going to be like what is this and then
you want them to ask and remember and
then yeah why is there a chicken up on a
giant fi you know what would that be
like 400 feet tall would it be all over
the building like his legs in one screen
like a piece of them and all the
different screens but if you stand back
far enough you can see the whole thing
the whole the whole chicken yeah but I
was like no maybe we'll just do you know
we got to figure it out but we want the
the personalities various personalities
Super Bowl ad at some point that would
be absolutely insane we yeah chickens
playing football
right that would be that'd be a really
big a cartoon but I think those are
substantially more expensive super Lads
are insane yeah but we could raise money
for it so like we weren't able to get
the actual package the uh I'll just tell
people like well maybe I shouldn't just
yet because I don't know what the
contract stuff is but let me just say
like there's a premium New York package
they have for specifically for New
Year's that includes like a national run
and it just costs millions of dollars
yeah and then when they called me and
they were like this is what we want to
do with with Tim cast and then I was
like wow how much is that and they were
like x million and I started laughing
and I was like okay dude like maybe next
year yeah maybe maybe one day I was like
but hey thanks for having faith and
thinking we're capable of doing those
things what we got is expensive but it's
it's like look we're getting 10 of the
of the of the boards so it's like not
like it's anywhere near that experience
you mentioned earlier but is it a
24-hour run on each board
all day every day for two weeks for two
weeks all day every day so we do a lot
of different stuff
yeah so technically you give them your
ad set and then they run it but you can
always send them updates because you do
how many like in a day different ones
can you run in one day I mean I'd
imagine as many as you want you to annoy
the crap out of them by telling them to
keep changing it it might be like come
on dude chill but uh we could do like an
update on Christmas because it's going
to be there through Christmas and then
on New Year's put you know something
updated for New Year's so you can
actually like what you're what you're
basically renting the space and they're
digital so you can change them to
whatever you want do you like some
hyperbox stuff like the world is
changing call to action of some sort
like stuff where like you are in control
it this is your world call to action I
think you know we we thought about doing
some kind of message like you are not
the elite anymore or something but I
think the most effective thing is
literally just a basic ad you are
because now talking with the Common Man
the idea is that if we make it an act of
a statement we set ourselves apart from
the from the the cultural establishment
if we put ourselves there the the
average person just sees us as part of
it so we've invaded that space we've
taken in their clout and then we're
going to have Luke standing next to some
of these people and it's just gonna be
hilarious
I just think that's funny a broken clock
is right twice a day and then show a
picture
time for Super Chat roll 20 and show me
throwing a die or something roll a 20.
yeah no critical success similar to the
ads we already have but we're going to
be at this party where they have like a
special area there's a live performance
VIP only indoors it's catered buffet and
the people who are there are apparently
like the New York royalty politicians
real estate owners and then it's gonna
be us
so uh I'm excited for that I think it's
going to be utterly fantastic
so but we're gonna go to super chats let
me pull up the super chats it takes just
about one second Luke say words while I
do this words words words words words
words words words words
are that's yeah backwards off the last
letter of the alphabet one more time Ian
yeah from start to finish
okay all right okay ladies and gentlemen
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become a member at timcast.com because
what are we going to do with it we are
going to like I don't know take over
Time Square or at least be as a part of
it for big events and where our goal is
just to keep pushing into the cultural
spaces we are working on the next
release of a song uh for our Music
projects and we've got uh some some Big
Industry guys that are working with us
so success is is happening now and you
know look you plant the seeds with what
the daily wire is doing the stuff we're
doing and many others hopefully in 10
years we've completely won the culture
war look Trevor Noah's out we're winning
baby let's read some super chats smash
that like button if you haven't already
Harry toe says hello Luke lately you are
looking amazing thank you I appreciate
that I've you know I have a lot of
people calling me very bold and very
beautiful I appreciate you very much
blue heart says if Ian isn't transformed
into She-Hulk this episode then
meditating didn't work like I thought oh
the episode's not over yet
Nova says if you put Alex Jones up in
Times Square I will up my sub to 25 tier
until 2024 do it it will drive them nuts
we'll see it's an issue of um we talked
to Alex I'm sure Alex say yes but there
are rules so they they could say no and
then you can't really do anything you're
renting someone's property like you're
it's a rental you know what I mean
but um we did think about it Michael
malice I thought was um the next best
thing we could do because there's
nothing they can really say about him
but he he pokes the bear very well like
a funny picture Alex with the tinfoil
hat on or something that might be a good
idea but what's the message right so so
it's a question of to follow it join us
but he's not like a part of the show in
any way you know Michael is like he's a
recurring guest who's done pranks and
gags that we've had on the show so I was
like it makes sense and and he he's very
effective in his challenge to the
establishment so we dig it
Beavis McLean says it now to our good
friend Beavis McLean Tim I audibly
cheered at your Times Square
announcement today I started I startled
the entire Supermarket but I regret
nothing love what you and the Gang are
doing I hope this helps fund more great
jamming
yeah man that was it I was just like
it's gonna be cool when these people
look up on New Year's Eve oh I just got
to tell you when they were when we had
the ads in Times Square these lefties
were tweeting like why is there a
40-foot tall Tim pool like what I'm
barfing and I'm just laughing I'm like
because we're winning dude and so for
them to be sitting at home with their
parents and like watching CNN and then
they just see it all big in the
background behind Anderson Cooper and
they go what yeah we're winning dude
that's it's uh all thanks to our
faithful viewers and members grafty says
bocus for president
bogus took a piss on the wall today yeah
and he stared directly into my eyes
challenge I look over and I see him
squatting in this weird way
and I'm I start yelling no I'm looking
and he's just looking me dead in the
eyes and he just keeps doing it I had to
run over and push him and make him stop
and then he runs off
what a dick
literally cats man
it's because we weren't letting him go
outside because he'd go to the doctor we
let him go outside but then he's gone
you can't find him to go to the doctor
so the other day to go to the doctor I
had to go outside with a can of tuna and
bang on it with a fork and then he comes
running
so we can't let them out you know
apparently bocus is constipated so no no
no we gotta figure it out well it's
probably from all the squirrel he's been
eating or something yeah he was digging
into those Bacons too like for a month
yeah replaced jump we had we had a bad
drawer so one of the reasons we run out
of bacon is that bocus jumped into the
box dude and was just digging through I
went into the box and there were like 40
open even half eaten Bacons with eating
plastic and I was like what we're out of
bacon she's eating plastic really it's
probably been as good yeah that's what
cats do they do they chew on plastic
they love it weird what's wrong with
them
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim I've
learned as a leader from the core to my
current position folks want to uh folks
want to know the truths and whys of what
is you ask of them leadership 101 yet
politicians fail daily with this simple
ask
yeah no that's a key leadership lesson
like you you know being willing not just
leading like an authoritarian like you
must do X being like willing to explain
to your subordinates why you have asked
them when it's appropriate obviously
sometimes there's urgency but as a
general rule it's good to have your
subordinates understand what you're
trying to accomplish yeah and why Earl
Gramps has been watching for years now
and loved the show today is my 33rd
birthday and I wanted and I wanted was
to motorboat Luke's tig old bitties but
sadly seems that he's been deflated how
dare you de-transition well just wait
that's all I got to say and uh oh no no
no just wait all right all right
David Scott says I've posted numerous
times I have no issues with
notifications that changed today I
changed my news seeking process
throughout the day and had to go to my
sub list get Tony Heller on the show
who's that don't know
and orange sea lion says if you only
have 10 it seems like the 10 of the time
is up CNN Etc will just use clever
camera angles to keep you off the screen
by all means I'd love for them to try
and do it we're still invited to the
party
so it is but look there's going to be
all of the people there on the ground
there's going to be all the photos taken
and when we we had we've had we had ads
this summer there were videos on Tick
Tock with millions of views of people
dancing and our ads are in those videos
so they can't do anything about it
let's grab some more super jets
Murph tries DIY says Nye uh billboard
should say it's over CNN I have The High
Ground that's a good one
that's actually very funny that's good
we can only do that if it's not an
advertisement you can uh when it's it's
so if we don't include the website we
can actually do that
but I don't know if it's worth it you
know we want to get the advertising out
of it right it's because if you don't
advertise it's protected Free Speech if
you are advertising it's commercial and
now you could be infringing on someone
can you have like one image that's an
advertisement then it morphs into
another one that says that that's not an
ad oh so it's either they're all
considered ads or none of them are the
the video plays for 10 seconds whatever
is in it is a single ad even if you
flicker through different images so when
we were doing we did the Taylor Lorenz
thing
when we said she docks lives of tick
tock and they said if you include you
know the website or commercial product
it's advertising and you're using
someone else's likeness they won't allow
it so because we didn't
and it just said it was quoting me it
was allowed
so good fun stuff Smokey Joe says not
trying to be a jerk but you are not good
with predictions and you've been on
every side of Civil War predictions
World War III will happen when I happens
um I don't know I've gotten some
predictions and I've gotten some uh
poorly wait you've gotten a prediction
wrong oh yeah once oh gosh I thought
like if you prognosticated you should
never ever get a prediction wrong it's
just like you have to have 100 here's
here's the thing
that people uh a lot of these people
like these lefties aren't smart enough
or they probably get it they're jelong
if there's a video
where I'm like Trump might get a 49
State Landslide I think they're
specifically referring to my Moody's
Analytics review where I was reading a
news article that said there was a
possibility of a trump 49 State
Landslide Moody's was referring to
Moody's Analytics in 20 in 2019 and said
the economy was so strong that there was
a chance that Trump could actually see
like a record number of electoral votes
and then I'm like wow like they're
actually suggesting this and then they
act like I'm making some Grand
prediction because I read an economist's
analysis of the you know of of the
country or something I don't know I just
see it as like everybody who you know
makes predictions gets some right and
gets some wrong like I'm a lawyer and I
get some legal predictions right and
some legal predictions wrong I'm not
perfect but also I've gotten a ton right
I'm sticking with my Elon is going to be
forced to buy Twitter prediction that
one I've been on for three months so
watch that yeah you're the first person
to say that to me yeah
gravity says Roberto Jr needs a cameo at
the ball drop uh I have news
we have secured a location for a brick
and mortar shop
maybe I shouldn't say what the name of
it's going to be well you know what we
wanted to name it Roberto Juniors but
maybe we can't actually do that
why do you want to talk about that on
air I think I think the idea for the
brick and mortar shop is that it needs
to be a a a a business into an in and
unto itself in and of itself oh I see so
brand yeah so you know making it being a
part of what we already do it kind of
defeats the purpose of creating
something separate yeah it's smart
that's why I was like we probably can't
call Roberto Juniors oh well but I gotta
admit like it's it's not like Bobby J is
it's only a matter of time before people
find out like oh that shop that sells
you know bacon is Tim's or something you
know what I mean
so we'll see what happens
Paul Morris says I I'm convinced Trevor
Noah quit because he couldn't compete
with Luke's Buxom display
thank you very much
that's how you spelled that wrong it's
b-u-x-o-m that's a great spelling great
word though it is a good word you know
what he was trying to say yeah I had to
think about it because it's phonetic
yeah it checks out
Dana Burke says everyone is too consumed
with pointing fingers on who blew up the
Nordstrom what uh when what we should be
focusing on is the consequences that are
to come
yeah well some of the consequences
depend on who blew it up in the first
place
like if the Russians blew it up I guess
doesn't mean they're going to attack us
because they blew it up
you know but if we did we escalated
so I don't know it matters a lot Jason
Lindholm says Tim I will bet money that
military Doctrine is if nukes are used
then retaliation is with nukes yeah yeah
but the issue is if Paul's none is that
he said pose none pose not gets nuked
with the U.S then nuke Moscow
well you have to think about how the
Russians would respond right like if the
Russians actually did nuke poznan would
they be doing so betting that we
wouldn't respond with nukes I don't
think so given that they're they're in
NATO so I think that probably we have to
go through the calculation of if they
knew poznan like a city we're not
talking about like a military tactical
news like if they nuke a NATO City they
have to assume that NATO is coming back
at them which means full-scale nuclear
war but then what do we nuke do we say
okay what's a comparable City St
Petersburg no we don't we once you you
know you don't nuke piecemeal
you just say Okay launch them all
I think nukes are the wrong thing to
look at too you'd think that in 80 years
we haven't come up with any other kinds
of weapons I don't think that anybody's
I honestly don't think anybody's gonna
break the seal because when everybody
the logic I'm describing is not novel
right like it's it's I'm sure both
Russians and us have like you know
Doctrine on the use of nuclear weapons
and and essentially what it looks like
in Kurt in particular situations which
is why I don't think Russia will use
them you think so well let's see who's
right we're talking about predictions
I think I think Russia is going to
threaten to use nuclear weapons but it I
think it's first going to declare a full
all-out war and I think it's really
going to put the hammer down on Ukraine
on its infrastructure and I think
hopefully for Lucky it ends there why
would why would Russia just be like well
we're getting crushed on every front I
Surrender because they already have
worth the land they need they have the
freeways to Crimea
I don't know that's that I'm saying if
they lose that if they lose Ukraine's
already take it back okay Ukraine's
already pushed through in many of these
territories they don't even control
these four regions
they've now made them part of Russia in
their eyes so how could they not defend
it if their ground troops are routed and
their Machinery is is routed would
Russia just be like guess we lost that
land that I claimed was ours we won't
defend or is he going to be like
tactical nukes or nuclear artillery
geez I don't know if you need to go that
far he's already reigned incendiary
bombs down in some of these cities
I mean you have to one thing though is
that Putin has been trying to do the
Ukraine war on the cheap right just by
the sheer number he's hasn't used many
troops that's one of the reasons that
Ukraine was able to make that big
advance in the Kharkov region is because
it's just a very thin Russian line
um and it's also why he's done the
partial mobilization now to bring in
like 300 like almost 1.5 x the total
military commitment in Ukraine so like
that's also one another reason I don't
think we're doing because I think we're
a long way down the escalatory ladder
from the use of nuclear weapons in terms
of I mean Ukraine you know Russia is
going to try and you know consolidate
its Victory you know consolidate its
territorial
um gains with this new troop movement
and maybe I don't know maybe try and
move on Kiev Jim Bob says you guys are
missing the issue Biden announced the
U.S will send divers to Nordstrom really
are they going to be picking up books
well where does Nordstrom sell clothes
clothes yeah Russia owns the Nordstrom
lines I don't think Russia owns
Nordstrom I think it's an American
company isn't it no I know what you mean
I'm just I'm just uh poking fun gym pop
means the us is going to be sending
divers to Nordstrom Russia owns the
Nordstrom lines we are going to get into
a shoving match if we touch that
pipeline
possibly Russia might be like back off
get your troops out of here this is our
line
that's interesting
Alexander cross says the correct way to
survive a nuclear attack is either a
find the bomb site and sit on it or B
get far enough outside the blast as you
can you get caught in the blast have a
revolver handy in case well that's if
you're caught in the um in the thermal
burn radius
so depending on where you are if you see
a you know an ICBM coming down or
Warhead dropping if you're close to it
your best bet is to run towards it
because then you vaporize instantly and
you don't suffer but if you're in the
thermal wave you're going to be like
screaming in agony as your skin is
melting and then you slowly die so
and then if depending on the weapon they
use if it's got a radioactive radius or
Fallout oh
man
I wonder if like really horrifying
things sarin's worse sarin gas is way
worse if when a human dies it's forced
to watch the evolution of the species in
Fast Forward after the moment they die
and you like see all the things that you
did in life how it affected everything
and because of you and your actions
whether for good or evil you caused this
to happen and here's how you caused it
and you just get to see it all and be
like the regret the amount of hell that
you would burn in if you didn't do what
you knew you could have done in life
so take advantage of it while you're
here what happens is you wake up in in
like a carnival and there's a Carnival
Barker and he's yelling and he shows you
a chart that has all of the different
probabilistic branches of your life and
they're playing circus music and dancing
as they do it and then you just like huh
so I would have been an astronaut if I
went to school and you know on that one
day if I didn't call in sick I would
have been a race car driver yeah I would
have saw that coming contingencies I
mean this is the crazy thing like if
they really if that I mean I I obviously
don't think that really happens but if
that were possible you could look at
someone's life and be like if when you
were seven years old you didn't pick up
that quarter you would not have been on
timcast IRL you would have actually been
in the Amazon building sustainable huts
and it's like wow that one quarter
that's chaos theory well it's because
you pick the quarter up which brought
you to another point where it's like you
could buy the bag of chips or not you
bought the bag of chips and then you
gave to someone that person became your
friend they introduced you and then it
creates this huge pathway that just that
coordination one conversation can change
your entire life yeah
Tommy groshong says Ian is on fire
tonight well done good sir and then he
says a word I can't I can't read all
Cyrillic yes all right that right there
is it it says um mono Ayu
molo ah it's far away I'm not able to
see it Mo that that's an L that L is the
curvy little n looking thing
I can't read that last letter also nice
to see Luke again will too no it's too
bad it's an upside down U no wait it's a
regular up it's a regular you but it's
got a thing hanging from it
I don't know how you pronounce that
maybe it's not an English word I think
it's oh interesting what was that how do
you say that Infinity
oh the human huntsman.net says I wrote a
song about the persecution of
conservatives using themes from
sultanitsen the Huntsman is free to
listen on my site cool that's cool
Hunter says rods from God cost too much
to use
what does that mean too much
yeah it's hard to get that much tungsten
outer space
I think that you're right though about
it's called kinetic bombardment doesn't
have to be tungsten yeah tinhead says we
don't have rods from God because the
tungsten rods are too heavy to send up
that and the rockets would have to be so
massive that they wouldn't get off the
ground with our current technology
maybe we have better technology how do
you know
at a time you know what if we have
anti-grav and we just snap our fingers
and then whoop floats right up
who knows
all right where are we in the old super
jets
Mexicali says you're not my dad Ian I
won't get in the van
you do what you think is right Panic
that says how did Ian avoid the van with
candy when he was five because his
parents have have to have him on a lead
strap he does whatever he is told by
anyone that's a funny assumption or are
you on strings no I'm actually very uh
I'm very confrontational and don't like
being told what to do no but like
children usually are like on leashes
sometimes
completely this makes no sense my
parents would have punish me like God
came down and smoked me with lightning
if I had done something like that smote
yeah Bobcat says Elon Musk is going to
win Twitter isn't clear breach of
contract and that's before you even get
into Twitter's epsteinish content
problem
well
um uh no
that's wrong uh Twitter did not breach
its contract what are you some kind of
lawyer yeah I want to write some kind of
lawyer uh smarty pants over here you
need to read the merger agreement bro
like it's not there's a reason Elon
talked about how seller friendly the
merger agreement was when he signed it
to get Twitter to agree to sell on the
company right and all this stuff he
wanted about the Bots like here's here's
the big winner and this is to understand
it in order to be able to terminate the
deal Elon cannot himself be in breach of
the contract right right that was part
of the deal and there's a clause that
says Elon had to use his best efforts to
consummate the merger that's how that
works right when you sign a merger
agreement basically what you're saying
is I will do everything I can to get
this over the line get the regulatory
approvals Etc so they have text messages
of Elon saying hey let's slow this down
wouldn't be smart to buy Twitter if we
if World War Three is coming after the
merger agreement aside that's breach he
won't doesn't matter what Twitter said
or what Twitter did Elon can't terminate
like it's there's so many ways in which
this is GG for you know Twitter's gonna
win this lawsuit but I don't want Elon
to win I want you I mean yeah say
actually no you're right exactly I don't
want anyone to win I want Elon to be
forced to buy Twitter yeah right like
yeah that's that would be much better
for us than the current management so
it's like we should be rooting for
Twitter right now to win so that Elon
ends up taking it and fixing it exactly
yeah and I think but I mean this is this
isn't actually a close question there's
a reason that the Twitter stock price
has been jumping since uh you know Elon
announced his quote-unquote termination
it's because most analysts have realized
that elon's probably going to lose Thor
says if World War III kicks off are you
worried about getting drafted Tim no I'm
36 it's gonna be the 18 year olds
fighting this war as per usual
a lot of the 18 year olds don't have a
lot of testosterone and don't have a lot
of bone muscle mass and if you look at
the conscripts in Russia a lot of them
are on the older side so it depends on
how desperate the situation is I do see
the future wars being fought with robots
but with enlistment at an all-time low I
do see yeah 30 30 year olds 40 year olds
possibly even being drafted if there's a
potential crazy situation
Asheboro says power is out here in North
Carolina generator is going and my
awesome wife who I love dearly is half
asleep leaning against me not a bad way
to end the night man that's crazy
hurricane Ian crosses over Florida just
wreaking havoc and then curves and goes
back into South Carolina that is brutal
when I was meditating on it I was like
I'm gonna disperse this this thing and
then so I tried to visualize moving the
wind in the opposite direction to make
it push to a standstill and then then
like vacuuming out that Center eye or
hitting it with lightning or something
like just charging it or discharging it
and it stopped I was watching the the
radar and it and it's paused for a
moment but I wonder if I just pulled it
back like a slingshot by doing that not
coming down you see what happened was it
was crossing here's Florida and it's
crossing over and then you were like go
the other way go the other way and then
it turns back in itself it was right
before it made landfall in Florida you
can see for a moment right before it
hits it stops and starts to go west and
you're like whoa did we just avert
catastrophe and then it goes in hard and
then it comes back around like a
boomerang
Wicked
it's brutal stuff man
it is unfortunate
David Troutman says never got a response
from my emails about building the Tim
Caster guitar ready to buy these
meteorite pieces and dragon scales got
to replace the defender behind you uh
yes
um send an email to
I don't know I have an email on on the
website so go to the website and you can
look up my email there you go easiest
way to do it
and then email me about it
STL phone fixer says your cat isn't
drinking enough water that's his problem
he's got more than enough water not only
do we have numerous little water things
for him we have the we have two water
fountains that filter the water and then
we even turn the sink on for him yeah he
doesn't really like drinking water
that's that's the thing about cats they
normally like to get there they don't
actually need that much moisture and
they like to get it from their food yeah
we give him all of the best possible
food and instead he's wants to eat
squirrel yep right because it's moist
yeah no we give him the moist crazy oh
you you give them a canned food we we
have fancy canned shreds we have with
all the different food and we're like
which one do you want and then it looks
at you and he goes yep and then you're
like I don't know what that means and
then he goes outside and he gets a
squirrel it was funny because he was
killing he was eating baby bunnies for a
while and we were we were making fun of
them because we were like it's so
pathetic it's like you're an adult cat
it's working out to it okay well he
still can't catch an adult bunny but he
got swirls so but we you're not like
nothing we can do about he's not
supposed to but that's who he is he's a
little little Predator he just wants to
kill you know it's it's in him oh cats
are predators
we didn't let him outside for a while
and the vet was like don't tick saw that
other stuff and he was obviously
depressed he would just lay and sleep
all day and he was getting fat and he
was just groaning and then we were like
this is no way to live you know it's
like maybe his life will be more
dangerous but that's life so now we let
him go outside and now he's a happy
little little jack off when we don't let
him outside he pisses on the floor so
he's figured it out those damn
texoplasmic spreaders toxoplasmosis
what do we got Tim McDonald says just
finished watching Hocus Pocus 2. here's
the breakdown one trans adult one trans
kid five drag queens one gay interracial
couple one patriarchy reference
I still don't know what the movie's
about Hocus Pocus well you know you've
never seen the first one no that Bette
Midler movie yeah oh God
no I'm good no is it good uh no but
everybody Millennials are nostalgic so
they pretend like it is oh okay yeah I
BET's all right she's a good actor it's
like the witches want to live forever so
they have to eat a kid
like I think checks out oh is that what
it is they eat the cake but it was campy
was it like a like a Disney movie yeah
so they didn't want to really eat the
kid like he was and then like ripping
them open or anything like that they
turned the kid's brother into a cat but
the cat's Immortal so like whenever the
cat gets run over just and reinflates or
something
brutal yeah and it can speak English for
some reason like the witches turns a cat
a person to a cat but like lets them
still speak English for whatever reason
okay
I don't know I guess people like it
whatever I don't think I'm gonna watch
the uh
I don't think I'm gonna watch that movie
Jeff the handyman says gas is back up to
525 in Washington well congratulations
to Washington you already put yourself
eight dollars and sixty eighty or
something in in California you guys see
that picture is that real yeah that's
right
what do we got
Porkins hold it says this war with
Russia and China has been going on since
2019. hack of solar wind under Trump
Administration China 2020 release of
kovid funding BLM rights fentanyl
illegal immigrants buying and sitting in
Farmland I mean some of those things we
just don't know for sure right
so figure it out I guess I don't think
yeah the the China coveted stuff I don't
think was an intentional release lab
leak makes sense because I don't think
you'd have seen U.S interests in China
working together if they were at war
with each other now lab leak makes sense
it's also why our you know why did we
poo poo lab leak so much because our
government was implicated right too I
don't believe in accidents and
incompetencies when there's so much
criminality out there it looks like a
fundamental difference between you and
Iowa yes you you believe in you
attribute to malice what I attribute to
stupidity exactly Thor says and we both
could be right
you're not too old to be drafted I am if
they uh unless they increase the
drafting age like they did in Russia so
that's a possibility but yeah I'm still
not worried about it I just I just I'm
not worried about it I think if it came
to the point that point it would just be
absolute breakdown in chaos in the
United States the the the the political
system of this country is so broken as
it is I just don't see that happening
but my friends if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends become a member over
at timcast.com we have an amazing
uncensored show Monday through Thursdays
you can check out all the episodes from
the week and going all the way back to
the start of the show
or at the start of this uh last year I
think we started in 2021. uh smash that
like button you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me at timcast
and follow our Twitter account timcast
news
for news stories from the timcast news
team will do you want to shout anything
out
um just the internet accountability
project the article 3 Project Check
especially
iapviap.org and uh the underscore IAP on
Twitter there was a big uh I mean we
didn't really talk about it because I
didn't mention it and or bring it up
before the show but you know there's a
big antitrust Bill yesterday that passed
and should have gotten a lot more
Republican votes he only got like 39 but
iip has been pushing for it Heritage has
been pushing for it so
um lots of good stuff for big Tech on
the or bad stuff for big Tech good stuff
for us I know Horizon you're uh you're
amazing in those cartoons an honor thank
you thank you Luke uncensored.com is my
website I did a very interesting video
on the larger agenda yesterday it's in
the members area I will be doing another
AMA on that platform soon you could be a
part of it on Luke uncensored.com and
thank you so much for everyone in the
chat room calling for the ukulele
milkers I appreciate it very much if you
guys want to get involved with taking
control of your life in reality learn
Russian as well you can go to where I
went last night which is
russianforfree.com and uh start there
it's actually very interesting when you
start to learn something that a lot of
people on Earth already know it feels
like you're coming home there's a sense
of like you you're supposed to know it
it makes a lot of sense you understand
why people think the way they think all
of a sudden and it's a very awesome
feeling I hope that you get a chance to
do that and take care of yourself this
weekend
for sure well thanks everybody for
joining us this evening with will our
good friend
um you guys can follow me on
twitterminds.com at sour patchlitz as
well as sourpachulates dot me
all right man it's been uh it's been a
great week we've got some fun weekend
plans so thanks everybody wait Tim Tim
before we before we end it here I I said
I was done I'm not really done wait I
gotta show you guys this what's he doing
let's see